Okay, and we're recording.
All right, it is 4:01 on September 15th, and we
will call this work session to order. I want to start off by excusing Zach.
He had some other obligations today. today, Councilmember Huish.
And just make sure— is Councilmember Wood online?
Okay, and Councilmember Wood is also online.
So glad you could join us. And, uh, we'll start right
off with the first item, 1A, discussion for
transmission lines. And, um,
Brandon? Yeah, thank you, Mayor. Um, I think
I don't need to belabor Kind of the background on this, we know
there's, we know about the transmission line project
that goes from Spanish Fork Canyon to the Mercer Substation.
We, you can see the preferred route,
even zooming in a little bit better, you can see it runs here in
the yellow, and that takes us right through
our ag zone.
So we came to you a couple months ago to
get council's feedback and see how you
wanted us to handle— we've got this project, this transmission line project,
we've got data centers that need power, and so we're like,
how do we— how should we handle this situation?
We need transmission lines to go through that area,
even though transmission lines aren't allowed in the ag zone. So the—
we were tasked, staff was, to prepare an overlay
zone. So we were going
to start working on that and then found out that Spanish Fork City
had went through a similar process of actually establishing an
overlay zone for the same purpose to give them
control of where that transmission line Would go through
their city, and then I talked. I spoke
with their community development director to find out kind of some background of why they
did the overlay zone, and then found out that they repealed that
overlay zone or abandoned it. You know, several months later.
So long story short, what it came down to was
there's a. There's state requirements in the way that
that really are a little bit of a challenge
to work with, and so that's from what I gathered from Spanish
Fork. My discussion with Spanish Fork City is they became
more aware of the state code requirements related to cities
and and the location permitting the and
and having a say in the the location of transmission
lines. And yes, there is an ability for
local municipalities to have— to
be able to permit these and place conditions on them.
But the— it looks like one of the big keys here is
providing safe, reliable, Excuse me, safe,
reliable, and adequate service to customers.
So,
like it says here in 54-14-201,
if otherwise authorized by law, local government may
require or condition the construction of a facility in any manner if
the requirement or condition doesn't impair the ability
of the public utility to provide safe, reliable, adequate service to
its customers. So we
have the ability— what it really comes down
to is oftentimes cities end up having to pay the
actual excess cost. There's whatever—
if our requirements cost
the utility additional money, We have to pay for it oftentimes.
Now there are some ways that that doesn't happen.
There is a board, and I'll get to that in a second, but oftentimes
it appears that we end up
paying what the, again, the code, the state code calls actual
excess cost. There's a process that cities
can You can go through this
process with the utility and have them give you the estimate,
give you an estimate of how much it's gonna cost, and you can ask for
competitive bids. But ultimately,
it comes down to this. Once those
actual excess costs are known and there
isn't, like it says in A and B, the Utility
Commission or the Utility
Facility Review Board doesn't intervene in
some fashion to absolve the
city from having to pay, then we end up paying the excess costs.
So there's your definition of actual excess cost.
It can even include right-of-ways, you can see
on the screen there.
This chat,
it's sub— or
Section 2 of 5414 talks,
kind of lays the groundwork for cities and
how they can interact in this process of requiring
conditions and so forth and permitting these transmission
lines. Last, the last bit
of language there, you can read that there. Any requirement or
condition in any permit, authorization, approval, or exception that
imposes an actual cost shall be considered waived. You basically have 30
days to, if you're required
to pay, you have to make that payment within 30
days before the construction
of the facility to avoid— anyway,
if you don't pay it in a timely fashion,
then your right
to actually have a say actually is waived.
So there is a board, like I said, the board
of The Utility Facility Review Board.
It is your 3 utility commissioners plus 2 other members.
I think the utility company and then city gets to
choose somebody from a group of people at the
state government level to participate in the process.
And they'll
hear disputes between utilities and cities
basically about you know,
excess cost questions and so forth. So I
just want you to be aware of this as
we can prepare an overlay zone. We just
want you to be aware of Spanish Fork's, uh,
Spanish Fork situation, uh, kind of their
experience with it, and we wanted you to be aware of the state
code requirements. And so with
that, I'll let you— I'm here to answer any questions.
Mayor, is it okay if I ask a question? I'm just wondering,
does it make any sense to the council to continue to pursue an
overlay zone knowing that this is already highly regulated at the state level?
I mean, it's really, in my opinion, it's a question of Do
we want to impose some additional regulations and are we willing to pay
for them? That's what I'm hearing. That's my interpretation of what
we just read through. Is if we feel strongly that
we want the power towers to
be covered to look like pine trees and it costs $100,000
per pole extra, are we willing to pay that? And I don't
know, that's a really kind of a silly example, but as I listened
to this, those were my thoughts. I don't know what the rest of you think.
So part of the reason for doing the overlay zone was so that we could
direct where those transmission lines would go,
right?
And just instead of, 'cause if we didn't wanna just put it willy-nilly and
then that anywhere, the ag it could go and then we lose control
of that. So that was part of the reason for the overlay. So is it
placing an additional condition on the utility if we're telling it where it needs to
go? Making sure I'm still on
there. If it impacts, if it
causes, if our condition ends
up costing the utility more money, yeah, it becomes
an impact to them and we have to pay pay more money. So if they
can buy a transmission corridor or an easement for X number
of dollars that runs right through this piece of
property, and we direct that it has to go through that piece of property,
and there's a cost differential between the two, we're going to have to pay that.
That's, that's exactly what I'm interpreting. And remember this,
they can— they're, they're a utility company, they can eminent domain anyway,
even if you told them no. They They can
do what they want.
I— part of me is inclined to let the market help drive
where the transmission lines go, because they're
in the business of providing power for residents, and in the long
run, if we require something extra We
end up paying for it either way, whether it comes from taxpayer dollars or if
it comes through ratepayers. So I think we need to be really
careful and judicious about how much we are
trying to control where this goes. But I also know that
when we first started this conversation, there's several areas
around the city that are ag-zoned, and we don't want
energy utilities just running through wherever. So It
feels like a lot of this is predetermined by what the state requires
us to help fund if we're the ones that are instigating the
cost. So it's a little bit of— it's discouraging,
I think, in a lot of ways to even talk about it. But I don't
know. But this relates to just the public utility. So it's not
private transmission lines. So it's just the public utility.
It's just public. So maybe the way the council needs to go on this is
we don't put anything in code and we just wait and negotiate once an opportunity
comes up. And then we can negotiate whatever we want,
including saying this is how it's going to be and regard
like and we can create in the code that they waive their rights to whatever
the state says. That's not the way that I'm seeing it.
I'm seeing that they basically. can come and secure
their own access and determine where they're going to put it and where
it's most cost-effective to do so. And that we really,
unless we choose to step into that process and
pay the cost of modifying anything
that's outside of what they're already willing to do,
then it's kind of a moot point. So if it's an allowed use,
for instance, and it meets every requirement in
an allowed use of a zone, basically staff-level approval.
So it wouldn't— you would never have the chance to weigh in.
Right. Well, go ahead.
Let's see what Rich thinks. Rich, do you have a— Councilmember,
what are you— I'm here.
What I'm thinking of is— I can't hear you, Rich. I can see you talking,
though.
How about now? Can you hear me now?
It's not muted. No. We'll come back to you.
Um, did you have something else you wanted to say?
I was just going to mention that I feel like part of our
issue too is that we're surrounded by a lot of
unincorporated land or land that belongs in a different
city. So, however this gets to us,
that will always play a role in it. And maybe that's why the state has
played a bigger role in determining what can
happen in this space. So, it's just a factor
that we always have to be aware of.
How about now? Can you hear me now? Is the Merkur
substation the only one that is looking at upgrades? I mean,
they've talked about a transmission line that might come from the Twila Valley.
Are there others that we're aware of? None others.
I mean, to me it just doesn't seem like this is something that we want
to battle. I don't know how the rest of council feels.
If there was something meaningful that we wanted to do and we were
willing to pay for it, then certainly we could find a path forward there.
But from my perspective, I think if the public
utility company— I want to be clear— the public utility company determines that this is
where the line should be, this is the most cost-effective route, and this
is what they're going to do to put it in, why do we want to
stand in the way of that? I mean, we want them to bring the power
to our valley. That's the other consideration that we need to at least
recognize is if they choose not to bring power to our valley, then that's
going to limit our ability to But
at least we're vetting this. At least we're talking about it. At least we didn't
just have something happen without us trying to think in advance. So,
like, we're trying to still play from the front, but what we're realizing is we
don't have very— we don't hold the cards.
You hold the checkbook is what you hold. That's how I see it.
I mean, you have the checkbook that says if you're willing to pay for it,
you can certainly regulate it in any way that you'd like to, but you're going
to pay for it. pay for it, and you got to do it within 30
days of receiving notice, unless I misunderstood
something. That's how I understand it as well. I mean,
again, there is this Utility Facility Review Board,
um, if I keep forgetting the name of that, uh,
yes, Utility Facility Review Board, that, uh,
can, uh, we, we can take an issue, a dis— some
type of disagreement, and have them rule on it. So there is actually
a process And a possibility
of this board, and the commission as
well, they can take actions that may lead to the utility
not imposing some of the regulations, or some
of the costs, I think is a better thing to say, some of the costs
that would typically come. So there's kind of a built-in review and appeal process
at the state level already. But there's not much— I
mean, we can't rely on that. Right,
exactly. They're not— it's not a good backstop. So we're still not
required to put transmission lines as
an approved use in ag. We just wait basically for the utility company
to come and tell us where they're going to go. Yeah, I— well,
again, yeah, I guess if we say otherwise,
it's just going to cost the city money, it looks like. It seems like
we can still open a dialogue with them though and say, hey, here's some preferred
routes we would really like you to go if possible.
Yeah, and we have that ability. Commissioner— or excuse
me, Councilor Wright has been in our
DRC meetings, and they have Rocky Mountain Power and their consultants
have come in the last few months to our DRC
meeting to talk about the transmission line and getting permits
and so forth. So we can continue to ask
for them to adjust their application in a way
that'd be favorable to the city. And we, of course,
have a council member on there who's well aware of what
happens on the DRC. All right. For now, while they're working on this other issue,
I'm going to let Councilmember Wood weigh in on the phone. Can you hear
us okay, Councilmember Wood? Yeah, can you hear me? Yeah, go ahead.
So, the couple questions that I have, first of all, is this not covered under
our overlay zone for the energy production overlay zone? And why
not just add it to the zone that we've already created? That's my first question.
The second question is, I think that we do at least want to have some
input as to the— how the
line comes into the city. I mean, obviously, it's got to follow a certain connection
route. Um, but we— I think we want to have some input
in what that looks like. They do that.
Yeah, um, we want to— towers or things like that,
I'm less concerned about things like that, just more or less the
impact of the line itself.
The alternative energy overlay zone, um,
it We can certainly,
we can require them to
go through the rezone process.
I don't have the code right in front of me. I don't recall that we
have specific requirements for transmission lines in there.
But I know that we also have in our 1770,
Chapter 1775 of the city code,
there are relatively few requirements
already in there related to transmission lines.
So I just don't know how much traction or how much it will help to
put that land in the alternative energy
overlay zone as it relates to the location
of transmission lines. And your other question, I'm trying
to— Can I ask a follow-up question to that, Brandon? Yeah.
Okay, go ahead. So the transmission
lines that we're talking about, are we talking about them coming from Spanish Fork
or from the actual natural gas facility?
From Spanish Fork. They'll, they'll come Can
you see the screen, Rich? Is that— No, they rebooted my computer. I think they're
trying to figure out how to get me connected, so I can't see anything right
now. They basically start in Spanish Fork Canyon, wrap around the
bottom of Utah Lake, and then cut through the
backside of like the Lake Mountains and
then into Cedar Valley. And is this the
direct connection to the, to the current line then?
Yeah, well, to the Mercer substation. Mercer substation.
Okay. I don't
really have any issue with the creation of a code, frankly,
but I think we can probably accomplish that with the overlay that
we have. I mean, I think for me at least, that was the intent of
that overlay zone for all energy production, including transmission lines.
I think Councilmember Wood, I mean, here's— I'm listening to what you're saying
and trying to kind of process it. I think that the
difference that I'm seeing is that this is regulated as a public
utility by the state. And I think what you're referencing
are those alternative overlay energy projects
that we perhaps may entitle in
the city of Eagle Mountain that are behind the meter generation
facilities. And I think that's the substantive difference in in
perhaps the 2 things that we're talking about. What are your thoughts about
that? I'm not saying that. What I'm saying is it's coming through the same
area. My understanding
is they do have to at least follow existing zoning, correct?
No, that's where they— I think they have the power of eminent domain,
so they don't have to.
So that's where we're at. What is the point of doing an overlay zone if
they don't have to follow any of the zoning anyway? Well, and that's the
crux of the debate. I think the question's
answered then. That's exactly what they've been saying. There's no
reason to do this if there's nothing we can do, right?
I mean, that's— those are— I mean, I think we are coming to
a consensus. That's what I'm hearing, is that if there's nothing we
can do to regulate it, then why are we trying to create Create a zone
that we can't regulate anyway. And if we do regulate it, it's just going to
cost us money. Yeah, only pertaining to public utilities. Yes.
Yeah. So, so maybe what I'm hearing is that
this overlay zone would work on a behind-the-meter, but in that case,
what's the impact? Do you want to do something for outside of public?
Well, I, I think our alternative energy overlay zone already contemplated
that, if I remember right. We'd have to go back and look at the language.
I think Marcus is— it talks about transmission lines in that, in that overlay.
And frankly, they're through the development agreements.
That's where we've given the entitlements to produce those energy,
the behind-the-meter energy production anyway. And so
I think that the city still has several levers that they can pull to
help design that in such a way that they're comfortable with the outcome.
So are we certain that they don't want to work with us on this in
the first place?
They, they have been cooperative. They— I think they're—
we— they came in to the DR to,
to get information about submitting applications.
Well, around the 1st of June, if I recall correctly, maybe May.
And we told them, so when we go
through that process, we just kind of give them a bunch of background information,
requirements they need to go through, and then kind of tell them about constraints they
may run into. And so obviously, this ag zone,
the ag zone not allowing transmission
lines, that was the biggest roadblock. And so they,
They actually were the ones that they've gently
just kind of pointed to the fact to the state code. They're like, "You also
might want to talk to Spanish Fork." And yet they didn't really
give me a lot of feedback initially, but they're like, "You might want to go
talk to Spanish Fork because they've been down this path and hear
from them what kind of their their experience with trying
to create an overlay." So I did, and I'm reporting
back what I heard, what I found out in my own code
So— So we good to move on on this one, or is there further
direction for staff? No,
I think— Doesn't sound like there's anything we can do. Exactly my thought.
I think we just say thanks for looking into it and bringing us this information.
And that helps us make a decision that it's better off not to make
a decision about this. Okay, let's roll
on. I'm going to keep you on the phone for a second, Rich, until I
find out if this is there, but I'm going to put it on mute.
So if you need something, raise your hand or something, we'll get to you.
Discussion item 1B, I think we're going to hold off on that one. I've mentioned
before the meeting, Councilmember Wood, I didn't get a chance to tell you, but that
was one that Council Member Hewish wanted to weigh in on, and I think we're
better served to hold off on that one to maybe
the next meeting. So if Lacey, if you don't mind putting that on a future
It is somewhat urgent, but I don't think it's super urgent, so we'll skip
by that one. And then discussion once— item 1C,
the discussion about the project recommendations from the community board.
Steve, did you have an introduction, or is this Turn it over to the board.
Oh, we can turn it over to Jesse, who's representing the board, and Charlotte's here
as well. So.
Give us just one second. I think we're
recording. Oh, we're good.
Just not what? No sound? I thought you were asking about Rich, but Rich
is not back. Yeah, we're good. I'll keep him on the phone for a minute
and tell— if something changes, we'll figure it out.
Okay.
Good afternoon, Mayor and Council. I really appreciate
the opportunity to come and present this to you today. And before I get
started, I want to recognize the strain that both our staff and our budget are
under right now. And the last thing I want to do is add
unnecessarily to either of those, which is why we took careful consideration in
crafting this list. I also want to express my gratitude for all
of the help staff has already given us on the Community Services Board. And for
all of the work that each of you continues to put into our city,
the information that we put together here came from a few different places.
We gathered it from discussing with residents at
different events in the city. There was an app that was created
that had customer or customer resident feedback,
and then a lot of this was just things that members of the board had
seen around the city.
We then dedicated the majority of one of our board meetings to discussing what we
believed should be priorities for the city, and we specifically
tried to identify things that could be meaningful wins without necessarily taking on
another massive project. And then we— from
there, I did some additional research to
better understand what could actually be feasible and what we could realistically
ask. Thank you. This is the
list that we came up with. I do want to point out that as a
board, we did not rank these recommendations beyond agreeing that they belonged
on this list. But I intentionally left them
this way because I know that funding is tight right
now and that it may not be feasible to address all of these immediately.
However, as I researched each one further, I found some pretty compelling reasons why
every one of them deserves consideration. Thank you. Consideration as a priority.
The first one is ADA curb ramp installations.
There are currently these, at least these 5 locations
that were pointed out to me by a resident where the
trail does not have an ADA ramp.
In the staff report, Steve noted that the average cost is approximately $4,450
per ramp. And that's not an insignificant amount of money.
And I don't know exactly how many there will be, but I do think that
they're important improvements for us to make. One of
our board members made a comment during our discussion that I think summed this
all up, and it's that our city should be accessible for everyone.
Did you have something? Yeah, go ahead. Yeah, I do have a question. And it's,
so at 44, 50 per ramp at each of these locations
that the board has identified. Are— does that mean there's 4 ramps at this
intersection, or is it just one? There's 5. These are 5 different locations.
5 locations. But let's take Shep's Ridge and Overland Pump
Track. Is it just one ADA ramp, or is it multiple ADA ramps at that
location? So there would just be one at that one, and then on the other
side is a different— so it would be the White Rock Road would be the
other side of the trail. Each of these 5 represent one ramp apiece? Yes.
Okay, I think so. Just real quick, I wanted to either get
Zach or Brad to weigh in. A couple of these we had identified earlier
on and might already be on some lists. Is that which is very possible?
True. I know there was one in down
here to the south. What's that called? Talking about Sweetwater.
Sweetwater. Is this and some of them the sidewalk was
meant to go 100 feet to the East or west,
and then there was one. So— Well,
Mayor, I think that there's already a funding source identified for these
ADA ramps from the CDBG funds. And that's why I was asking.
I mean, didn't we talk about that? Yeah, I think
that we've had communication that that funding could be utilized
for something of this nature. Well, I— yeah, so I think this one's a
no-brainer. Me personally.
Awesome. Can I just make one point before we move on with that though?
On some of these, we need to look at them because when we build ADAs,
we gotta be careful. Like, is the trail continuing through and
does that create a crosswalk scenario?
Is the ADA intended to be there or is there an ADA at
the corner, at the intersection,
and this is a cross-section road? Definitely willing
to look at the list and you know assess it, but there's a few other
variables I think we need to look at through that process. That's why I was
wondering if there's additional feedback because I know we looked at one down here that
has that exact question. So we
can look further into those. All right, good. Can I ask just a quick question
too, Mayor? Since we only have this one item,
have we fixed the loophole? In our requirements
for neighborhoods so that this stuff doesn't happen anymore?
How did we get to the point where one of these trails didn't have
an ADA ramp?
I think that's something that we're going to have to assess on a case-by-case.
I think as we develop our subdivisions and the
communities, we look at those plans and we try to make sure that those cross-sections
are there and the ADA ramps. exist. Um, some of these areas,
uh, I'm, I'm not familiar with these intersections, so I haven't seen them,
so I'll have to go out and look at them and assess them. But,
uh, it's, it's definitely something that we try to collect
in our DRC, our plan reviews, and try to make sure that everything's compliant and
in line. I, I totally get that, and I
know that you guys make great efforts to make sure all
of those things happen, but I'm wondering if we need to have something in our
code or in our process that would
make sure that these ADA curb ramps
are there, just like we require that there's X amount of streetlights
and X amount of park amenities and things like that. So I'm just wondering if
this is something we ask the planning department to take a
look at code-wise to help—
Make it always work out the right way?
I mean, we can definitely look at anything and put it in code, but I
think what is gonna really dictate this on how these
exist and whatnot will be these future master plans
with our trails and whatnot. They should outline and show
that connectivity. And, you know, when it comes to ADA and
sidewalk, there's other plans in place,
and there's some other plans I think us as a community that we're going
to probably have to get involved in because, you know, ADA is one
of the biggest compliance things that we have to follow. And we're trying to
get on a maintenance schedule. We're trying to add these additional ADA ramps
and those things as they come up. So the best case scenario I can give
you for today with this is we can assess each of these locations and
see if it warrants it. And if And if we— if it needs one,
or we'll do what we need to to get it installed.
Thanks. Can I add just one other thing too? So if you're saying,
Brad, that there might be a ramp down, like, down a
ways, if the rest of the family's going this way, but they've got an ADA
and they said, well, now we're gonna have to detour to bring you in,
I'm still open to adding more ramps to make it better for those
that are traversing. And I hear you. If it's a through
cross— if it's a trail segment that's crossing a roadway, then we need
to assess it in that situation. But that's not true in every scenario.
Sometimes trails go to a sidewalk and they tee.
And that's what I'm saying is we wouldn't want to put an ADA into the
roadway on a tee. That's why it needs to be assessed.
This might have an ADA ramp a couple hundred feet to the east
at a stop sign. And this is mid-block where you're— now you've got a crosswalk
situation or something. So we need to look at those. And then
I was just going to— I think I know the answer to this. I don't
remember that $4,450 was a number that you got from engineering,
or is that? From streets.
Okay, Steve got it from— I just—
and we're pretty confident in that number, right? Yeah, that's reasonable.
Okay, just so that we know the fiscal impact. Go ahead.
Thank you. Our next item is trail signage.
The off-street trails master plan that was recently passed
identified 39 signage-related issues throughout our trail system.
And some of them are a little more than just an inconvenience.
There are blind intersections where ATVs and mountain bikes can meet without adequate
visibility or warning. Trail difficulty isn't always
marked, which means a beginner can unintentionally end up on a much more advanced trail.
Boundaries aren't always clear, making it easy for someone to leave designated trail without realizing
it. And in many areas, the permitted
uses aren't obvious, so users don't know whether it's a trail for
bikes, ATVs, horses, or anything else.
Our recommendation is
to create cohesive signs that
address all of those issues that would improve safety and make
trails easier to navigate. and create a better experience for everyone using them.
I love this one because I think one of the things that we hear a
lot from residents is either enforcing something that
should or shouldn't be on a trail,
noise from certain things that shouldn't be adjacent to
backyards at 3 in the morning, just different things like that. And I think having
good signage defining what is there,
Both for the
ability and the difficulty of a trail, but also just
to help people understand what's allowed there and not is the first step
into being able to enforce something down the road too.
So I hope we can fund this.
Is that 39, meaning there's 39 identified locations? Yeah.
Okay. Just as we go on, and I actually
wrote down I like this one too. Melissa said that. I just don't want it
to fall on deaf ears. So as we get going, great presentation. I just want
to make assignments. So keep that in mind that— It said 39
issues. It could be that there are locations, but I would assume
that's what that means. Mayor?
Can I just ask— Can you guys hear me yet? So is that 39 pertaining
to the app? Is that how that is correlated?
'Cause then you collect this information— No, this is from the off-street
trails master plan. This is from— okay. So there's no correlation back to the app.
I just was wondering if that's what the 39 was.
No. The next one we have
on here is benches at Smith Ranch Park.
Smith Ranch Park is an awesome park, and it has 3
different playgrounds and multiple fields and cool wildlife area,
and it's It's— there's a lot for families to do there.
However, around those playgrounds, there's nowhere to sit. And as
a mom who has taken her kids there to play, it would be really nice
if there were benches or something to sit
on so that I wouldn't have to bring a camp chair to watch them.
It was noted in the staff report that it would be just under $1,000
per bench. We also had the thought that if
it were allowed, small businesses, or not necessarily
small businesses, but businesses in the community could donate a bench.
Because I know they're always looking for opportunities to give back to the community,
and I think that would be beneficial. I don't know how many benches we would
need, but at least a few around each playground
would be awesome. I also really like this
idea. One thing that I've heard over the years of serving from different
neighborhoods is when someone from a neighborhood passes away,
like a small child or something like that, almost always I
have residents reach out and say, we want to do something,
we'd like to donate this memorial or donate something.
And I think this allows us to achieve
2 things. One, provide more seating, but then also
a standardized option for creating a
memorial bench in a loved one's honor. And I think
we could do it as a pilot program at Smith Ranch Park,
and as we see how that works,
we could potentially expand it to other parts of the city so
that people can designate where they'd like for a memorial bench to be placed.
And I like that the park staff is picking out
the quality and type of bench so it's not just
some kid's Eagle project, but it's actually something
that will stay and last in a city park.
So. The next one would be the maintenance of
the rodeo grounds. This is something that I've heard from several members of the community
who own and ride horses. And particularly one member of our board who
this has been an issue for. Currently, the grounds are groomed
and prepared like a week before the rodeo
each year, within that week.
And then within about a week after
the rodeo, I've been told that the arena surface becomes difficult or
unusable again, and it generally stays that way until preparations begin for
the next rodeo. And when we're talking about maintenance, we are
specifically talking about maintaining the dirt surface pictured in this
to the left, not maintaining the entire facility.
Um, however, during my research, I did find that the current
lease agreement with Pony Express Events could create some confusion about
who's responsible for certain types of maintenance, and so that may need
to be reviewed. Um, but ultimately,
our recommendation as a board is that the city take on the responsibility for
maintaining the dirt and add it to some maintenance schedule
like with the rest of the parks in the city.
Our next one is more of a
fun one. We are recommending wildlife-themed
utility box art. This was brought to us by a member
of the board who is also part of the Wildlife Alliance. And the idea
is to take some of the utility boxes through the city and wrap them in
artwork similar to these examples. The estimated
cost is about $1,000 to $1,500 per box, and we would need to coordinate with
Rocky Mountain Power to determine which boxes could be approved.
And there are, as far as I understand,
funds set aside from capital projects that are restricted to
be used for public art, and we thought that
this would be a really creative use of those funds.
We also thought that it would be great to provide
some community engagement for— and we could have like an art contest and
decide which pieces of art could be displayed on these.
And the art itself should last 5
to 7 years if we wrap it in vinyl.
The next one is Nolan Park. I think we all
know that Noland Park has a lot of potential, but right now we're not getting
everything out of it that we could.
The fields are used, but the baseball diamonds aren't configured to accommodate
full baseball games. The splash pad's unusable, and there is
nowhere to park. Our recommendation is that the city begin
the process of a redesign of the park sooner rather than later.
It's intentionally lower down on the priority list because the IAE recognized
that redesigning and eventually rebuilding a park is much larger and more expensive undertaking than
several of the other recommendations.
But it would
be useful to at least start the process,
gain resident feedback, and see what it is
that we want to build and where— what
direction we should go, if we have to do a new splash pad or not.
I know that that's important to a lot of residents. I heard that.
just to gain resident feedback and see what the next steps would need to
be and if we need to hire a firm. But we, we believe that that's
something worth considering at this time.
Really quick, um, I think that this is
important because it's something that's been talked about for several years,
and I think we just need to rip the Band-Aid off and start
working forward with a plan. If we can't pay for something
for a while and we need to phase it in smaller chunks, that's okay too.
The one thing that I want us to make sure we consider is
Nolan Park East, which is kind of
like a section not in the main square of Nolan
Park, but is to the east of it. It's got a pavilion and
quite a bit of grass space. South of the church there?
It would be north of the church.
Along there. It's along, what is that road over there,
Peregrine? Yes. So it's right along Peregrine and
it faces the townhomes right there. There are,
when I've been there at Nolan Park East, I've seen a lot of people take
their dogs from the higher density housing and
go over there and let their dogs run and play in that area.
We've talked about community gardens that might be a place that's
near density. And I
think that since we have kind of a community garden pilot program we're starting
up, this would be a great second location to consider. But for sure,
it's important to me that we're looking at Nolan Park
holistically and not just the square, but also Nolan Park East.
Thank you.
The last one is a— it's about a
championship-level disc golf course. And I want to emphasize what
we're actually asking is not for the city
to select a location or design a course
or spend money constructing one. Our recommendation is to engage with
Firefly and explore whether this is something that could make sense within their
community. Pictured on the left is our current
disc golf course, and it works for casual play, but it really isn't suitable
for more serious or avid players. The space is confined
enough that longer throws can end up near or in people's backyards,
which is not ideal. Firefly has expressed some interest in potentially
having a championship-level course there, and they have consistently looked for
opportunities to bring unique amenities into their community.
So our ask is just that the conversation is had with Firefly on if this
is something that could— that they could be interested in,
and then if they are, that you guys seriously consider allowing
and supporting that opportunity. But of course,
they have not committed to anything. So that
is all. Thank you. I really appreciate you taking the time to hear these
today, and if you have any questions. Yeah, let's— I know we're going to back
up a little ways. Uh, I've got Council Member Wood on the line again,
and we'll go to him for some questions. Did you want to go back to—
Yeah, yeah, I just have a couple things just to address. So with
the signage, I think you're right on those, but I think we need to codify
this so that everything going forward has those safety standards in place.
And then we need to put it on a schedule to go address that while
we're efficient on all of our Trails.
Trails. And again, I don't think we have the money to do everything all at
the moment, but if we don't put a plan in place that addresses how we're
going to pay for these things and get them in, uh, into a routine of
getting updated and fixed, it's never going to
happen. We'll be talking about it again in a year. The second thing,
uh, I agree with the assumptions made about Miller
Park, but I maybe would like to see a little different approach. I think that
we have other parks that have problems as well, and we need to have—
this would be something that would be a real benefit from our Community Services Board
to evaluate what is the most meaningful
first for each of the parks, to put that in a priority list,
and then let's put a plan together to start addressing them.
Because I think it's more than just Miller Park. I mean, we're aware of what
the splash pad issue is. But I think that there are other parks that require
the same type of, uh, to be addressed.
And if we don't put it on a plan to address them, then it
never gets funded. Rich, she did mention
park benches at, uh, Smith Ranch was another one, and then Nolan
Park. And those were the 2 main parks, but definitely
had those too. I don't have an issue with putting
the benches in. I think that's a good amenity. I mean, people can use them
When their kids are playing, people who are walking and want to
take a break, or runners, or people that just want to sit at the park.
I think that's an amenity that should be in all of our parks.
I just want to agree with Council Member Wood. I think that we've talked
about making some upgrades to even at the Silver Lake Park where
the amphitheater is and the playground and the walking trail around there.
This might be a time to imagine what else
could go there. We've talked about landslides that are
on the side of the hill there and just different things, and maybe beefing
up and adding bathrooms down by the amphitheater part
so that the summer camp that takes place there every
summer has an actual place for them to change in and out of costumes and
just different things like that. So I like the idea of
asking our Community Services Board to look at all of the parks and help
prioritize some of the most urgent needs.
I'm okay with that, but I'd want them to have maybe an email or
something to say, hey, look here, and this is an idea, because otherwise it's just
kind of throwing darts. So if it's things like the slide that I know we've
talked about, I just, I want
to make sure we're giving them good direction. Mayor, I think that we need to
make sure that we're doing this in conjunction with our new parks manager.
I'm assuming the global plan that they're going to be providing,
and I think that they should be working with the Community Services Board, but I'd
like to see a maintenance plan to bring the parks to a level that I
think we're all comfortable with, which is going to require assessing each of the
parks and where they're currently at with their landscaping,
the equipment that's there, the trails, etc. I think
adding what Melissa said on top of that, finishing some of the parks needs to
be part of that. But if those aren't all prioritized in,
you know, going to this park, here are the things that needs to happen.
We go to this park, here's the things that need to happen. We need to
put those into some sort of a budget plan or it will never happen.
Yeah, and just probably a good time to tell you a meeting that I had
earlier this week and, uh, with our parks manager Kyle. I told him
that I think he should start coming to council meetings, especially when
these things are on the Agenda. And then not only that,
also direction to start sitting in with Steve. Steve's got
a heavy lift right now, and we invited him to start sitting in
on these— the monthly meetings, because I think that for
now that most of what we're talking about affects him anyway, right?
And Steve and I talked about that.
And I did speak with Kyle, and he was not available to come tonight
to this presentation. But he is planning on coming to our board meetings
whenever they're available. Yes, sir. Definitely on the same page there. I think we
saw that same hole, and I think that's important.
Was there other comments on some of those,
or anything you wanna see kind of pushed up the list?
With that now out there, we already know
there's some funding sources for some things.
I would like to say, sorry, were you gonna hop in? No, go ahead.
I would like to say that I really do support us having more
regular rodeo ground maintenance. I know there's been kind of an evolution of what the
city takes ownership of and what the nonprofits
take ownership of and different things like that. But for it to be consistent
and cared for with the proper equipment and all of those things,
I would like for us to find out what that fiscal impact's
gonna be on us to take that on, and whether we can work that into
the schedule. And even if it's once a month to start instead
of once a year, that at least is pushing us more in the right direction.
Because it's a huge asset. If we support the Western
way of life out here and our Western roots, then I think we should take
care of one of the, you know, The biggest amenities that we have that
reflects that. So I really support that. I'm glad that it's on the list.
Yeah, I just thought, well done. I'm grateful
for the presentation, Jesse. I would just say that I'm supportive of looking at
all of what you've brought forward. I think the ADA ramps is
a pretty straightforward thing, assuming that our staff finds
that they'll be compliant. They're in the right location,
and I like that there's already a ready-made funding source to take care of that
that comes from outside of the city.
Okay, those those CBDG funds I
think can be used for that. The trail signage certainly okay
with that. We it's just a matter of where do we find the resources to
tackle that. The Smith Ranch benches I love what
you said, Councilmember Clark. I think. I think offering those as a memorial
bench and having folks purchase or donate
them makes a lot of sense to me. And if not,
then we can look at something else. Rodeo maintenance, I don't disagree with
that. I guess the question that I have and the suggestion I would make is
if we're going to put more resources into maintaining that, then should
we be looking for an opportunity to rent that space out?
Reserve that space to do something that's outside of perhaps,
and maybe that's a good or maybe that's a bad idea, but I just want
to open up that at least that line of thought.
The wildlife— can I jump in on that for just a second? Just so I
remember this year, it would have been our budget discussion
a year ago. We bought a new tractor and I said keep that old tractor
and let's use it over there. I don't know how I'd have to get some
feedback from staff about how much the old ones used compared to the new one,
but we only ever had one. Now we have two. And the thought was that
it could sit over there, just like mowing the grass at the soccer field.
We don't necessarily rent that out. It would get too much abuse
possibly without the, you know, things in this type of
an industry get damaged. But I think open
riding for our residents and having mowed grass type of— I'm open
to all that, Mayor, and I'm not disagreeing with you in any way.
You're the horseman. And I'll certainly respect that.
For me, it's just a matter of can we find it, can we
find a way to make that more useful? And I think that's probably the goal.
Yeah, and I wanna just, so for context, I guess what I'm saying is just
like putting gas in a lawnmower and mowing the grass once a week, we're gonna
put gas in a tractor that we already own and take 15 minutes to plow
the dirt. That's the extent. And if that's all it takes, then let's, I mean—
I think that's what they're asking. Yeah. Can I, let me finish. Go ahead.
Maybe one step further on that. Uh, I think that—
aren't we also supposed to be using the tractor over in the Memorial Park as
well for, uh, the cemetery?
Isn't that why we kept the old one? I think is the question.
And I don't know how much use is over there or not.
I, I don't know off the top of my head. I can't, I can't answer
and say that it's this many hours, but yeah, there's several different pieces that equipment
that gets transported around and used for several different items. If we
don't have— Both tractors are in use, I guess, would be— Yeah, we use both
of them. Just at this point, our city's getting big enough we could have a
third one, right, Brad? Well, it's just time and money,
right? I mean, I've, I've taken time and I've, I've groomed the rodeo grounds.
I, I— you say 15 minutes, but I think it's longer than 15 minutes to
turn that arena. I think it's a couple-hour deal. And if you're going to
do it 3 times a week, those, those numbers add up. And so I think
we just got to look within our budgets and see what we can facilitate.
And if it's a service level thing and we want to bolster it
up and we want to provide the services and more time and money and staff,
then, then we can, we can do these things for sure. Yeah, go ahead and
finish, Brett. All right. And then probably just the last one that I'll comment on,
and everything else that's been said I agree with, but the wildlife Utility boxes.
I like that idea. And I, again, there's, I think,
a ready-made funding source that's available for that. And I think that you
tried to identify that. So you, I thought I was waiting for you to weigh
in on this. 0.25%. Yeah, the quarter. The quarter percent that we're collecting for
capital projects. On capital projects. On capital projects that's being set aside into a special
fund for art. I think it would be nice to start to put some
of those funds to work. And I personally think this is a
good place to start. Are there other things we should
consider? Certainly, but this would start to give some return on those
collections that we've been taking. Just for context, I think there's— we
were trying to figure that out today. We got a phone call and Ben and
I were at the Capitol. There's about $49,000? $48,000, I believe.
$48,000? At one time. $47,000 in that account
just on capital Probably just a quarter of 1%. Yeah, and I don't think we
need to spend it all here, but I think that you could certainly identify,
you know, a half dozen or 10 of the most impactful
locations and then work through, 'cause we have to develop
the process as to how you're gonna pick artists and who's gonna decide what
goes on there. And that's a whole nother can of worms
that we gotta work through. All right, I wanna
go back to Councilmember Wood real quick. Was there more on that one? I just
want to jump back to the rodeo grounds. I think that we need to make
a decision of whether or not it's a park or not. If we're going to
treat it like it's a— it's always going to be in disrepair.
If we're going to treat it like it's a park, then we need to make
it available to people. People need to be aware that it's there for their use
and we need to maintain it as such. But I think we
can't continue to pretend like it's not something that we need
to maintain. Because we're really touching it once a year.
So if we're going to make it available to everybody, then what is the use
that we're going to make it available for? Are we allowing it to be a
riding arena? If so, that tells you exactly what type of surface we
need to put in there as far as the dirt goes. If we're going to
let people come in and do other types of things that's going to commingle the
dirt, then we'll have to scrape it before the rodeo every year.
Um, I had a similar thought to Council Member
Wright about, well, maybe we should be charging for it and different
things. But then as I was sitting here thinking about it, we don't really charge
anyone to come and use our pickleball courts or our tennis courts or anything like
that. It's an amenity that we put in. Um, if someone's
going to— Maybe just schedule it. Yeah, schedule it. Or if someone's
going to make money from it, like if they're going to host a A big
event that's— 4-H. Yeah, 4-H something or other,
or something that's not necessarily city-driven.
I, I think maybe then we could look at some sort of
fee schedule or something. But in general,
I think that it's our duty as a council to figure
out how to fund the maintenance and care of that
space. And then, um,
as we go through people using it, if there's inappropriate uses
or something like that, let's cross that bridge when we
come to it. Yeah, I just— my understanding is that it is in
use already. It is open to the public year-round.
People come in, they bring their dogs, use it as a dog park during
the off-season, and people go in and Do other sort of recreational
activities there. It's just a question of, you know, we have
an agreement that puts the burden of maintenance on a particular group
and it's not working out and how should we move forward?
I think that's the suggestion that they're making is that perhaps the city should look
at that and say, is there a different approach we can take to for the
maintenance of it so that it becomes an even more utilized
facility than what it is currently? I mean, it's certainly being
utilized, and I'm aware of that, Marcus.
But I think that at least what I'm hearing is how could we make it
a little more useful for more people? That's what I'm hearing.
Yeah, I would agree with that. I mean, I think that we've listed
it as one of our parks. That's supposed to be what the use of it
is, so we should be maintaining it as such. And to Melissa's point, I don't
think that we should be charging people unless they're trying to reserve it like a
pavilion. If they want the full use of the facility, then they go through the
same planning or the event— what is that—
reservation that everybody else does for pavilions or a portion of the park. And we
have a fee schedule that's set up for that. Otherwise, it's available for people to
use, and there probably ought to be some At least some restrictions about what
could be done on the dirt.
So I think what I've seen in other cities, I'm just floating this out there
for you guys to consider. For instance, it's just open riding, and the
key here is that the ground's in a condition that it can be rode,
you know, rode in. Compare it to a pavilion. The pavilion's there,
there's tables there, you can sit down, you can eat lunch, you can come and
go as you please. It's open to everybody. If you want to rent the pavilion
or block it off to where others can't use it because you have a birthday
party, You call the city and you reserve the pavilion for $30 an
hour or whatever that is, and then you have your event and then you go
on. And that's, that's exactly how Spanish Fork
and other arenas do that. That's what I'm talking about. So, so there's— if you're
the 4-H and you want to block off from 7 to 9 on a Monday
night, you call in and you pay your $30 an hour
fee type of deal, and— or $50 or whatever, that would be
in the fee schedule. But it's open riding unless you're bringing in an
approved use. I agree with that, but I also think
that we should have an application for a fee waiver for specific
things that are serving our community. For example, the FFA
kids at our local high school may need it for something specific,
and they may need it to be blocked off specifically for them, but they're
not a for-profit entity. Mutton busting. Yeah, mutton busting.
They are kids that are growing up here in this community And I think
that there should be a mechanism by which organizations
and people can request that that fee is not assessed
or waived. So that's just something that I also think that
the Community Services Board could help tackle. Okay. I was just gonna
say, 'cause I haven't chimed in, I'm very supportive of what the Community Services
Board's been doing. Super grateful for what your work is, and I'm really good
with your recommendations. And my one question, Can RAP tax dollars go towards some
of this? Certainly. Any of it. Absolutely. And since
we have RAP tax dollars, it seems to me that this plan can be implemented.
So I think we go forward. I think my understanding is that RAP
tax dollars could go to any of this, yet there's other— Except for operation.
Well, there's also additional restricted funds that we use as well.
So for instance, the ADA would be RAP tax and/or the CBDG.
The trail signage would probably be RAP tax. The maintenance of the rodeo
grounds could not be RAP tax is my guess. That's it. Right.
That could still be RAP tax. You can use it to fund operations.
Oh, okay, there you go. Yeah, you actually could. My question
with that would be we're currently developing a process by which people apply for RAP
tax funding. Is this something that would need to go through that process for things
like this? I don't think that it should. I've seen that other cities,
Lehi specifically, There's a chunk of that money that
the city designates to go toward projects that they've
heard from the community broadly need
to be done and taken care of in their parks. And then there's a chunk
of their rat tax that the community service or rat board goes
through and makes determinations and awards grants and different things
like that. I think that there will be certain things
that we as a body who has that responsibility over
all budget and all funds to say, yep, this chunk is
gonna go to take care of some of those needs that have been
identified by the Community Services Board and identified by
listening to residents and still meet
that objective of letting the people on the Community Services Board be able
to weigh in on how those funds are used.
I think that's kind of, that's one of the things that I've said for a
long time is, I like that they've come with the initiative of these are some
kind of low-hanging fruit, as I would call it, that we can do. Like the
Smith Ranch benches can be funded with sponsorship
money, but that it's— we can do
this with all kinds of different funds, and that's up to us to
allocate funds on whatever that looks like, right?
So some of it could be RAP tax, of course, but some of it could
be all kinds of different How long do you want to wait for donations
to come in on Smith Ranch Park before you decide we just got to do
it ourselves? Like, I don't want this to hang out forever saying we're waiting.
So I think you put a deadline out there, you say we want sponsors,
and if the sponsors don't come in by a certain deadline, we build it ourselves
and not wait. What method are you going to
use to solicit them? I think that needs to be decided, right?
Like sponsorships? That would be decided.
Remains to be seen. Can the city help with advertising for
that, for the sponsorships? Are you talking about for benches?
Sorry, Councilmember Wright.
I think it could be just as simple as the process that
they put in place for the banners on the sides of the pickleball
courts. But it also could be something that's listed
where we have our cemetery plots. Like, if they're memorial benches,
we could put them there as an option for people to purchase
as a part of that. And then they also could be listed where
we have sponsorship opportunities for rec-type stuff.
We already have— And if you slid a piece of paper into their utility bill
also. Sure. We already have an amenity,
like, replacement repair line item. And it's
something that we could add some additional benches to out of— that's in
our— that's already budgeted for. And so I, I don't
think we have to go to the level that like we want benches there and
we have to go to a memorial program. I'm not saying that you, you can't.
You guys could develop a memorial program and that's something that we could implement.
But I think we could get some benches in sooner with some of those
funds. The other thought that I have is I think it's going to be good
to go out and obviously assess the parks and whatnot. We do have
our asset management program that we've been trying to get
all of our data into, and that's playgrounds, benches, everything.
And one thing that we gotta be aware of is sometimes, you know, we're gonna
make large purchase scale items like playgrounds and whatnot,
but we have to be protective that we wanna try to use those out for
their useful life. And that's part of what this asset management program's And
so as we see things in disrepair or whatnot, we definitely want to know about
those things. But then we have to weigh it against the overall condition of it
and a replacement schedule of it as well. And so there will be some balance
as we work through that. We're willing and we're trying to develop
that, and it's getting a little bit better each day. Obviously, our playgrounds,
our benches, our trash cans, our pavilions, and all those things—the high,
the most visual things are the first things that we put in there and we're
trying to manage that. But what that's gonna do is that's gonna kick out a
maintenance or a replacement schedule long-term too.
And we have to be careful. And the other thing I wanna bring up is
after these amenities are installed,
we can't use impact fee dollars to replace them. It's general
fund dollars that will replace these. Impact fee dollars can only be used when
we're developing or we're continuing that level of service in the community.
So I think it's just important to make sure that we distinguish those pots
of dollars and where they'll come from. But every time that we add a park
in the community, we gotta make sure that we have that longevity
in it built into it that we can replace it over a long-term period of
time. So I just wanted to add that for the record. Thank you, Brad.
And Council Member Whiting, I think you're right. I mean, look, I would certainly be
okay funding some benches sooner rather than later. With this caveat,
I think there's still an opportunity to— because you can use impact fees
to do that. It's a new improvement, right, Brad?
If they don't exist technically, we probably could use that for
them. I think we went on the shorter end on Smith Ranch
because as we— me being heavily involved in the process,
we go through a design process of a park and then we hit a price
threshold, right? Yep. And then you try to figure out how far you can make
your dollar stretch and try to develop this park out. And some, some things just
have to get cut when you're doing a price, when you're doing value evaluation
engineering and you're doing it on the fly. Like, some things get cut and
it's just part of the process. But I know that it seems small,
and but everything in the scheme of the picture, it adds up.
But I like the idea of putting them in early and then finding someone that
wants to donate some money so that they can memorialize
someone that they wanna memorialize and just have a system in
place so that we can just add a little placard or something to do that
to even an existing bench and then allow those funds to
continue to grow and perpetuate upon themselves where
we can then, rather than an
impact fee, those dollars begin to fund some of the replacement.
So just real quick, I wanted to
double-check with Lacey if it's possible. Rich, do you want to try?
I think maybe the microphone's working. Do you
want to try the other? Yeah, can you guys hear
We can move on. How about now?
No, I see him. Yeah, I see him talking and his sound's off, but it's
not coming through. Okay, we'll continue working
the way we have been for a minute. Councilmember Wood or Carson's going to try
and see if we
can— so any other feedback for Jesse and the board?
Can I talk again, Councilmember Wood?
How about now? That rules out that. I wanna
hear who's the Pirates of Penzance.
Nothing. Okay. How about now? So is that something that you
would like the Community Services Board to develop, would be a mechanism to get either
sponsors or memorial benches going? Yeah, I think that would be cool.
And I would say, I don't know that they necessarily have to
be sponsor ones.
Maybe they're memorial or honorary, honorarium type
benches. I like the
idea of us funding our benches, but also having an opportunity for
people who wanna do something for a loved one that's passed away, so. It's like
buying a brick or some of the other projects that we could do.
Is there any other thing that you wanted us to work on? Like some of
those other parks like the— I got
plenty. But I'm happy to add more. The, like, the amphitheater
and some, you know, prioritize some of the other parks, which I think they've been
doing. I don't— just haven't had time to report yet.
I definitely think that should— I'd like to see them take the parks and
prioritize them. What needs to be done at them? How do we get them up
to a service level that we're comfortable with? And then give us the opportunity
to do a funding schedule for them. Yes,
I have that written down. Yep, got that on the list. So, all right,
awesome, good work. Thank you so much. Make sure you tell the rest of the
board that doesn't come every time that we appreciate them too.
Thank you. All right, just sit tight,
Rich. I'm gonna set the phone down long enough that— but you're still with us.
So, uh,
going right along, that's all for our discussion items, and then,
uh, We'll look to our manager Ben
for any information items.
Over the weekend, I sent a lot of information items out to our council in
a series of email— emails that I'm sure was a little bit overwhelming,
but we have a lot of great work going on in our city, citywide,
with different projects and planning, funding undertakings,
and infrastructure improvements.
With that said, I just want to extend appreciation to our staff for all the
good work that they do and ask the council if there's any questions that you
have on anything that's been shared. I think just because it's
a work session, this is a good chance to talk about what
we got done today. Yes, if you want.
Yeah, do you want me to talk about it? Yeah, do you want to talk
about— okay, if I find something I need to fill in, I will. Okay,
so, um, today we, we, uh, met, had the opportunity,
uh, to meet with House Speaker Mike Schultz,
and he was very gracious in welcoming us to meet
with him about our transportation needs specifically within our community.
The meeting was set up by our representative Stephanie
Grecious, and she attended that meeting and helped facilitate
that for us, and she did an exceptionally good job. I think there was some,
some maybe fear interpretation walking into that meeting that
perhaps we might come in with tons
of demands, and I think they were
very pleasantly surprised that we were coming in with ideas and solutions on how
to meet those demands. That we see ourselves as being a partner with
the state, working on economic development opportunities, working on transportation
and water opportunities, and recognizing that if we
are to continue to grow as a region, not just Eagle
Mountain but Saratoga Springs and West Lehigh as well,
that there has to be transportation relief to our area.
And some of those transportation funding dollars are already programmed out to
2032 and beyond. And so some of the ideas were, how can
we get state funding allocated to
meet the needs of our area and
do so in a manner that we could either self or work with our
development partners to try to self-fund some of those projects
with state dollars coming in in later years to help program and offset that.
That would benefit us specifically because we would be
able to undertake those projects today and then provide our residents immediate
relief. But second and most important, we would be able to
do it at a less expensive price than it would be to construct
in 2030. 2033, 2034. And so if we can do those things up
front, that saves dollars for the state as well over their long term, and it
opens up things for, for our entire region. The concerns
expressed by House Speaker Schultz was that he wants to make sure that we
don't circumvent or break the process. We have processes in the state of Utah
for funding, but in articulating
that the processes that we have had locally have been maybe
a little bit broken to some degree because we have larger geographic
areas with less representation on boards like MAG,
where other parts of the county have smaller municipalities
with lots of mayors and funding can go to different areas.
And everybody wants a bite at the apple, and yet we really need to look
at what are the, what are the roads that are failing and
how do we address those failing roads, and how do we do it in the
most expeditious way possible. And so our
ask was really not to circumvent or earmark or circumvent a
process. It was really how do we fix the process so we can work together
to meet the needs and demands of our area. The mayor did
an exceptionally good job sharing our story that we're
adding as a community more than 200 cars per month, adding to
our overall region when you add Saratoga and West Lehigh to it,
nearly 500 cars per month. And the programming dollars are already spent.
And by the time we hit the next available funding cycle,
we will have 24,000 more cars on our streets.
And sharing that story and laying it out on a map,
but doing so in an empathetic way, saying, look, we, we have a desire to
help the state meet its needs because we want our kids and grandkids to live
near us. We want to have opportunities for them to have homeownership,
single-family homeownership, not necessarily everybody
living in a condo or a townhouse type of thing, but we want them to
have the same opportunities that we had growing up here and living in Utah.
And, and so being able to align our priorities
with the state's priorities and being able to find solutions along the way turned
out to be a very productive meeting. We certainly appreciate the House Speaker if
there's anything that he maybe appreciated the most is that,
is that we were direct. We came to him with solutions.
We weren't trying to necessarily lobby things from him, but we were trying
to find solutions together in partnership with him and,
and do so on face value to meet the demands of our community.
And so the mayor did a great job. Stephanie did a great job.
David and Evan were both there. They did a great job. I just sat in
the I sat back and watched them all, and I was just glad to be
part of an exceptionally good group. I think going
into that, Speaker Schultz was probably, yeah, everybody's got
needs, and what makes yours more important than the others? By the time we
got halfway through the meeting, he extended our time by almost double,
stayed and visited with us, and said, you know, we've really got to address this,
and kind of got on board with we've got to figure this out.
As David has pointed out, I think our current funding for
things like Lake Mountain Road is 2033 to 2045,
roughly. Well, Lake Mountain's not even funded right
now. It's currently in plans. The Phase 2 is the
'33 to '42. Yeah, so that's Phase 2 of SR 73,
and I think we've shown that both those roads will get done before,
you know, we need those or we can't continue. I think we
made headway, you know, on some of the things that we were trying to do.
So I just wanted to make that report and let you know that we'll
just keep the foot on the gas pedal, I guess. I think they were pleasantly
surprised because I really feel like they were maybe a little nervous
and a little— Yeah, what makes us different? A little
defensive, maybe a little nervous about meeting
with us. And I think they left feeling like we were partners. I thought it
was a very positive meeting. And making us stand out to
why are we different than everybody else that also has needs, but we were able
to identify why. So I think that's, we're going in the right direction.
So anyway, any questions on those meetings specifically,
comments? No? Okay.
Any other update items? They're in the emails, right?
Ben? I think that's it. That's it? Okay.
Then let's go on to the consent agenda real quick.
Let's see.
So there's a proclamation on 9A that I was just
looking at, and I'm wondering if Councilmember Whiting wants to read this when we get
to that. I'd be— I'd be happy to. Okay, I got it here.
Then, uh, we will go to the change orders,
which were Mr. Salazar.
Yep, I can have— I have a presentation I included, and I'm happy to go
through it if there are questions, or if we're good with it, we can just
move forward. No questions. And Council
Member Wood, I think he's still here. No question.
And for the record, that will close out the No questions.
Okay, uh, minutes September
1st. Nothing.
Uh, preliminary site plans. This is, uh, Mr. Lemons is back
there. Is there any questions or presentation? No?
Anything? So one item I had on, on the— I know
this is on the consent agenda, but there is a Planning Commission recommendation
for Spring Run Plaza Lot 2.
And so I think when we make the consent agenda approval,
we probably want to call that out specifically, that the PC recommendation
is also— just so everyone's aware what that is,
make sure they agree. What was the— I'd have to look it up. That was
just my notes. Now we got to go take a look deeper, but whatever
it was, I liked it. So did everybody else— do we want to just pull
it off of the consent consent agenda since we have such a— No, no,
you can make the motion. I'll read, I'll read it for you.
It says the Planning Commission forwarded a positive recommendation to City Council for the
Spring Run Plaza Lot 2 site plan with the following conditions: the east elevation
be clad in at least 60% high-quality natural
materials. Staff note that the applicant has since updated
the east elevation to contain at least 60% high-quality natural materials.
And the shared parking and maintenance agreement be filed with staff as
as part of the site plan application. And as I read it, it's 2 parking
spaces that they're short on too that they wanna share with Lot 1. Yeah,
and it's really, so they, of those conditions, Condition 1 has since
been met. So it's Condition 2 that is the shared parking
and maintenance agreement. So you're okay with that?
Yeah. Yeah. Recommend, okay. You're good. Yeah, you're good. So as noted,
we'll just make that into the motion.
15A, resolution of Eagle Mountain approving the agreement with
Utah Public Solutions LLC to provide lobbying services.
No question? Pretty straightforward on that? Well, okay, so the question I
have, so I guess maybe this was just included in the material, but I think
pages 5 and 6 were the submission from the
lobbyist with the terms he wanted,
is my guess, because the terms, the term that was in 5
and 6 was different. The dollar amount requested
in pages 5 and 6 were also different than what was in the
actual contract. So I guess, was that just provided to us for our visual reading,
and that's not actually incorporated into the overall agreement because the term and the,
the pricing were different? Right, the, the pricing is what's part
of our agreement. Um, the, the $40,000, that pricing was
negotiated afterwards after receiving that
The proposal was brought in as an exhibit more to help delineate
what the scope of his specific offerings will
be as far as what he'll contribute to our needs as a city, not necessarily
the cost proposal that's part of there. And his— he
needs to update GOEO to GOED as well,
'cause that was outdated. True, yes.
So is it identified which one is approved in the consent agenda if they're different?
I know the answer, but it's the $40,000? Yes.
Okay.
He'd requested, I think,
$80-some-odd thousand. If it was full-time services, but we've got them
on a job-specific, and so that's what what the
change was. I just want to make sure that the contracts— we're comfortable with the
way the wording is. Yeah.
Um,
just did you have another comment, Council Member Wood?
If no, I had one quick— I had one question. I was
just trying to remember what it was. It was actually not I don't have a
question specific to the site plan for
the one over on Spring Run, but I saw something that I wanted
our staff to take a look at, and you reminded me about it when we
talked about a drive-through. There is a restaurant
that I believe is in American Fork or Pleasant Grove where they have a
double drive-through that helps to accommodate some of the problems with
having multiple drive— or multiple fast food places in a small area.
The name of the restaurant is Tava, I believe. I'd love for
you guys to take a look at that and see if there's a way we
could implement something like that for some of these smaller parcels
where they want to do those drive-throughs.
What was the name of the restaurant? Tava. It's an Italian restaurant.
Italian restaurant Tava. T-A-V-A.
Okay, thank you. We can look into that. We'll look at that during
the break. Um, the next one,
15B, right? Is that where you said we were? Uh, Mr. Draper,
that's the Spring Run Partners, uh, reimbursement agreement.
Yeah, this is in relation to upsizing
that's being required by the city for that development. The lion's
share of that is the upsizing of Wagstaff Way. So which will
increase certain construction costs.
Additionally, there is some upsizing of water pipes and stormwater
and wastewater pipes,
but that would take the balance of the agreement. This is
just the terms of the agreement as far as us reimbursing
them for the upsize. Any questions on that one?
Okay, we're good. The other
one— I just want to be clear,
Mayor. I mean, you wrote this, Marcus. I just want to make sure this is
clear, that this agreement would not cover the cost of purchasing the additional land
for the wider road. Yeah, that's coming at a later date in a future agreement.
Just wanted to make sure that— Yeah, this is just for the construction costs for
the developer. It's not the purchase of the land from the landowner. Just— that's
clear. I wanted to make sure that was clear. Thank you. OK,
now there's one scheduled item. We do have a little bit of time,
I think, before we're ready for break, so I do know that
there are probably some clarification and things would be good to talk about this.
Is that all right? On the budget amendment. So Terrence, if you
would like to present this. This has to do with our
first annual budget amendment.
There are a couple of things that we definitely wanna
make sure to get in this budget amendment. One of them was Silver
Lake or Woodhaven, but the roundabout there at the bottom of Silver Lake, I believe.
And it's a design. Yeah, so Terrence
has some slides he's gonna pull up. We can talk through this. So we can,
yeah, we'll just wait until you get there 'cause I know it's probably to the
Mayor and Council, I don't know if you want me to do the full presentation
later since there's a public hearing, but I can touch on some of the changes
between what's in the packet and— I think the highlights, and, and maybe
just, uh, because I do want to see the presentation one for the public hearing.
Sounds good. So jump to the highlights. Okay,
so pretty much, um,
I sent you an email this morning about, um, a couple more projects needed
to be added on the budget amendment for tonight. Those are the eagle— some
leftover money for the Eagle Monument project, the digital
sign info, and also the fencing for the wildlife corridor,
which is tied to a grant project as well. Um,
I'll go over— sorry,
aside from those rollover projects which already approved
before There are 3 more projects that will be added for the budget
amendment discussion for today's, um, tonight, today's meeting.
The first one will be the Pony Express Widening Phase 1 construction.
That will be from Eagle Mountain Boulevard to Shadow Drive.
The amount being requested is about $1.8 million,
and the construction is planned to be starting on February
2027. Um,
part of that project is removing the median and also going
from 2 to 5 lanes, so a widening project. And then the next
one will be Pony Express, which is the Phase 2. The design—
the proposed is to put some funding for $250,000 for the
design for this project, from 3
to 5 lanes, adding some improvement for traffic
signals and also realigning some of the Paul Canyon Boulevard and the Point Express intersection
as well. So this one, the Phase 2, will cover
from Shadow Drive to Public Works area.
And then the last one is the Silver Lake Neighborhood Improvement
Design. There is a proposal of $250,000
for the design plan for this fall.
This is, uh, to do roundabout removals from the
Woodhaven and Silver Lake area, and also Golden Eagle and Silver Lake
to become Woodhaven, to replace the traffic signal and also
do some realignment with road and crosswalks as well.
If you have any question, I have David here as well.
Would you go back to the fence and trail? I didn't know how
those were related, so I was curious. I think it was 220.
$25,000 maybe? Let me open up the— sorry,
it will be a lot easier to see it from here. Let's see.
Wildlife fencing.
Give me one second. It's opening up. All right, you've got it right there on
the right. New asphalt trail, Walden Park to Cedar Corners.
I don't know if that's the same one, and that's why I'm confused.
Give me one second. Sorry. There you go. I don't know if it's
big enough, but let me make it a little bit bigger.
The one that I emailed this morning is the additional money,
about $474,000, and that will Let
me just find the exact one.
So this is the new— let me just— It was on the same line
item with the— Yes.
The first one will be the $6,800 for the leftover
for the Eagle Monument, and that is to cover some of the landscaping portion of
that project, and it's about to be done sooner.
And then the next one is the— it was part of the budget amendment
from last fiscal year, the $268,000 for the digital sign projects,
and just— we're just rolling it over for this current fiscal year.
And then there is a grant money that we got through the Division
of Wildlife Resources that Todd was working before.
That's about $200,000 also that could be rolled
over for this current fiscal year.
So these are the 3 projects that— That makes sense. In the email it said
that it included a trail, and I didn't know how the trail was,
was, uh, correlated with that because they're kind of different
areas, but maybe it was different. So my other
Question or clarification, Brad or Zach could maybe weigh
in. It's right there if you leave it on line 88,
basically the asphalt trail from Walden Park to Cedar Corners.
Do you need to include from Cedar Corners
to— Mayor, are you referring to this $25,000
project later? I don't think we need to adjust
anything really. I think really what we're trying to here in
the fund is obviously we received some grant money for this
project, correct? Mm-hmm. And this is showing that we have an expenditure account
so that we can bill the resources and the materials against it.
We just, we just need it for bookkeeping and whatnot. So,
and then once we submit all the funds, whatever we end
up using on that, which we anticipate we'll use the full $25,000
on that project, then we would submit that for reimbursement.
But it's just really— it's an expenditure account that we have to show
that we can spend the dollars for the project.
Any other questions as to what was in our packet?
We'll wait for the public hearing for the rest. If there isn't, let me make
sure. Councilmember Wood, did you have any other questions on this?
If you didn't stop me, I'm going to assume you're good. No, I don't.
OK, perfect.
The training— Mayor, before we move
on from this, I know that as we are traveling today, we are
talking about some potential changes that would come maybe potentially by motion.
Would you like David— That's— they're in here. That's the ones we just talked about.
The Woodhaven— that was the— that was the Silver Lake and
then the the, uh, Point Express, the waiting,
the design. Yes, they were in there.
So as it's presented, we'll, uh, either by motion or as presented.
Uh, the next one was the 17A,
the training. Marcus, does that need to wait for the next meeting, or can we
do that right now? We've got 20 minutes, maybe. It's going to take more than
20 minutes, so we'll talk fast.
This is, uh, annual training on open public Meetings Act as well
as municipal ethics law. Can we start it and continue?
Go ahead. Mayor, we are talking about— we
have a portion of our closed meeting that would need to start at 6 o'clock
because of other attendees, but there we
could cover other things prior to and maybe take care of all of those things
so that we don't necessarily need to come back after the entire— If we
can get it all done, that's what I was trying to either do, this one
or that, and I'm I think it makes sense to use the time for closed
session. Okay. In that case, I'm open for motion.
I move that the council adjourn to a closed session pursuant to
Section 52-4-205, subsection 1
of the Utah Code Annotated. Second. All right.
We have a motion by Councilmember Whiting and a second by Councilmember Wright. And I'm
going to start the vote with Councilmember Clark. Yes.
Councilmember Wright? Yes. Councilmember Whiting? Yes. Councilmember Wood?
Yes. Yes. All right, we'll adjourn at 5:36 to a closed session
and be back at 7:00. And, and we will start sending
a link to Rich. Yeah, he's got it. All right.
Good. Stephanie's good.
Okay. All right. Before we get started,
Councilmember Wright is going to offer a prayer.
Our Heavenly Father, we're grateful to bow our heads in prayer on this Tuesday evening.
We express gratitude to live in this free country and this beautiful city and,
and to be citizens one with another.
And we pray thy Spirit be upon us as we consider those
matters of business that will come before the council tonight, that we'll be kind,
respectful, listen, and be
able to disagree without being disagreeable and express our
opinions and Amen. Pray for any that may choose to offer public comment
or engage the council or the mayor on, on any level this
evening, that, that they'll feel heard and have that opportunity
to express their thoughts and feelings and help us to have listening ears
and feeling hearts. We express gratitude for
our first responders. Pray thy protection and
safety upon them, as well as our military military families and veterans as
we, as we know that they find themselves in harm's
way from time to time. Help us to be neighborly and look after one another.
These things we kindly ask in the name of Jesus Christ. Amen.
All right, thank you. It is 7:03, and I'll officially call this
policy session to order. Before we
get started, I just wanted to mention Councilmember Hewish and Councilmember
Wood have been excused. They have some prior obligations. There's a
chance we'll get Councilmember Wood remotely, but maybe
not. Looks like he's off for the night. So we
appreciate all of you guys that have made it here. And it is the 15th
of September, 7:03. And as we
get started, we'll have Deputy St. Peter lead
us in the Pledge of Allegiance.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States
of America, and to the republic for which it stands,
one nation Under God, indivisible,
with liberty and justice for all.
Thank you.
You kind of acted like that was a surprise, but everything we do around
here is throwing you right in the fire. So thank
you. Start off, there's actually— I know
of a couple of things, but hopefully Steve's ready.
From what I understand, there's a couple of information items. I was at a UFA
meeting this morning. Um, Chief— or, uh, I almost called you
Chief Perchet. That's pretty good, right? You just want his pay too, right? Chief Fossum
was there with me, and we learned some cool stuff. And I know as a
city we've, uh, been working on some, uh, e-bike regulations
and different things like that. So, uh, go ahead. So,
um, as I'm— as Steve is coming up to, uh, show that video,
I'll go over the other information items if that's okay while he gets
set up. We'll just need to have the thing set up there. Some of the
other events coming up this week is Days of Service, Tuesday,
September 15th through Thursday, September 17th. So look
for your opportunities to volunteer and serve throughout our community
to make a difference. Fall dumpsters are coming Wednesday, September 16th
through Wednesday, September 23rd at Quarry Ride Park. And so it's a great time to
clean up your homes prior to winter. Eagle Mountain Academy
begins Wednesday, September 16th. This is our Citizens Academy,
and we're excited to bring our 4th cohort through and to
share what goes on in our city. Utah Rotor Pathway
Fly-In, Friday, September 18th, from 4:30 to 6:30 PM at
Cedar Valley High School. A helicopter will be landing at 4 PM.
There's a farmers market, of course, every Saturday from 9 AM to
1 PM through October 10th at Cory-Royd Park.
There's an adaptive trick-or-treat Saturday, October 3rd,
from 2 PM to 4 PM at City Hall. And then our movie in
the park Saturday, October 3rd, 7 to 9 PM at Cory-Royd Park.
That is the memorial park featuring Hocus Pocus.
And with that, I'll turn it over to Steve to play this video. We're going
to watch Hocus Pocus.
We know e-bikes and scooters are becoming more and more popular in our communities,
especially with our kids. Unfortunately, we're seeing a significant
increase in the number of injuries with riding e-bikes
and scooters. We want to get your attention.
E-bikes and e-scooters are not toys. They are vehicles.
Here at Unified Fire Authority, we want to make sure that everybody understands
the risks of riding, knows how to ride safely, and has the proper
safety equipment and wears it every time they ride.
Riding a traditional bike requires physical effort to build speed.
E-bikes and e-scooters are different. They provide a lot more power
with little to no effort, making it easier to reach higher
speeds. That combination of speed and minimal effort
can make it harder to recognize how much risk you're taking
and how quickly things can change. More speed means
less time to react, which can lead to very serious
injuries, especially when not wearing a helmet. In 2025
alone, Intermountain Healthcare emergency rooms across Utah treated 536
people for e-bike and e-scooter injuries. Furthermore, only about 40%
of bike trauma patients were wearing a helmet at the time of their crash.
A new state law is now in effect requiring e-bike and e-scooter riders
under 21 to wear an approved helmet when riding on public
roads. Ideally, a full-face helmet, which offers the
most protection. These statistics are concerning,
but there are steps we can take to avoid many of these accidents and injuries.
So, what can we do about it?
Parents, pay close attention to the e-bikes and scooters your child
is riding. Make sure it's appropriate for their age.
Helmet on every ride, every time,
no exception. Teach your kids to follow traffic laws and
signs, ride at a safe speed, and always stay alert to what's happening
around them. At intersections and crosswalks, teach them
to yield to drivers and pedestrians, never blow through an intersection,
and make sure both parties can see each other before proceeding.
Make sure they're wearing visible clothing and have proper lights, especially in low-light
conditions. These simple steps can help keep our kids safe
every time they ride. Remember, e-bikes and scooters are
not toys. They are vehicles. So let's all work together
to make sure that our kids make it home safely every time.
Chief Fossum, we— this is a great video. Is the OFEA okay
if we put this on our website and also post it on our
Facebook page? Great, thank you.
Yes, I just wanted to bring that— something that we looked at this morning.
I know as we look at code, also at safety, I think it's just
a good reminder to teach our kids, first of
all, that helmets are required under 18 on e-bikes, just like motorcycles, under 21,
and that they're not toys or vehicles. So the,
as a reminder, as we kind of, I think this is just an evolving situation,
the e-bike situation. So anytime
we get good information like that, I think we can bring it to the public
and share, so. Thank you. Wanted to bring that out.
With that, we have introduction.
You're good, Mayor Council. Mr.
Reeves, thank you. Before I introduce one of our newest deputies,
I was going to introduce both of them, and I'll publicly apologize to Deputy
St. Peter. He was not ready to come here and give the Pledge of Allegiance.
So, um, but, but thank you to him for that.
Before I get into that introduction, just let me first thank you,
all of you, and Eagle Mountain staff for all the hard work they've put in
over the last several months for, you know, especially dealing with some of these financial
decisions that needed to be made and, and, uh,
and that you guys have worked through. So thank you. Um, and again,
on behalf of the Sheriff's Office, thank you very much for that. So let me
call up Deputy Deputy Cunningham.
So in the past, as I've done, I just want you
guys to meet some of our newest deputies. We have a lot of newest— new
deputies. St. Peter has been here for a little over a year. He comes to
the table with experience. But tonight I wanted you to meet Deputy Cunningham. She's new
out here to Eagle Mountain. She is not new to law enforcement.
Her career kind of started in dispatch many years ago. She spent about 8 years
in dispatch and And she spent 5-plus years on patrol
with another agency. During that time, she was involved
with criminal investigations, special victims investigations. She was part of the traffic unit.
She is currently motor certified, and I think she's
been authorized to ride our bikes already. Close to it? Close to it.
Close to it. So we'll get her certified as another motorcycle rider
here in Eagle Mountain with one of the 2 bikes that we have out here
available to them. So you might see her out here doing some
traffic enforcement. Some of you may have met her already. I'm not sure if you've
met her in that context yet, but— Anyways,
I just wanted to introduce you to her and to the citizens
of Eagle Mountain. I think she's super excited. We are super excited to have her.
She comes to the table with a wealth of knowledge, with a lot of experience,
and is a great addition to our team out here in Eagle Mountain. So welcome.
Yeah, I'd say, I'd say welcome for sure. I've already had the opportunity to do—
I can't even remember what we've done, but you've helped me on some calls already,
and luckily you haven't been the one to pull me over yet.
So, although it has happened, and it's a great challenge to pull the mayor over.
So it's just a matter of time. I got pulled over last week pulling
into City Hall of all places. Again, thank you
guys, and I thank all of you, and thank you, Deputy. Appreciate it. Appreciate it.
Thank you. Yeah, welcome. We love
our guys, our law enforcement, and we've had a lot of
things. But yeah, I think so. You're afraid
of this one? No, you were going to— Oh, I was just going to say,
I think we should clap to welcome you to our city.
All right, thank you. The next item on our agenda
is 9A, the proclamation of Eagle Mountain City proclaiming Eagle Mountain as a just-served
city, right around the corner with 9/11. Craig's going to read
the proclamation. Okay, proclamation proclaiming Eagle Mountain City
as a just-served city. Whereas Eagle
Mountain City, Utah recognizes that volunteers are an essential part
Part of a strong, connected, and thriving community. And whereas meaningful volunteer service
provides opportunities for residents to build relationships,
develop a greater sense of belonging, meet community needs, and make a positive
difference in the lives of others. And whereas JustServe
is a service that connects individuals and organizations with meaningful
volunteer opportunities in their local communities, helping people find ways to serve.
According to their interests, abilities, and availability, and whereas
Eagle Mountain City desires to encourage and strengthen volunteerism
throughout the community and to help residents discover opportunities
to serve their neighbors and improve the quality of life in Eagle Mountain,
and whereas the city recognizes that service is most
powerful when residents, organizations, businesses, and community partners
work together toward the common good,
And whereas designating Eagle Mountain City as a JustServe City
demonstrates the city's commitment to promoting volunteerism,
connecting residents with opportunities to serve, and supporting organizations
that seek to make a positive difference in our community.
Now therefore, be it proclaimed that Mayor Jared
Gray and the Eagle Mountain City Council do hereby
designate Eagle Mountain City as a JustServe
city and encourage residents, organizations,
businesses, and community partners to participate
in meaningful service opportunities throughout our community.
Dated this 15th day of September,
2026.
OK, thank you, Craig. Marcus, just as a reminder,
proclamation executive, or do we need to accept that by motion?
I think historically we have just done it as
an executive proclamation. Okay.
Well, it's included in the consent agenda, isn't it? Or no? No.
Okay. That's why I was wondering if it needed to be.
Just executive? I think that's what we've done historically. I think we should continue
with what we've always done. Okay, be it done.
Um, next item is, uh, public comment.
Time has been set aside for the public to express their ideas, concerns,
and comments. As a reminder, public comment is an opportunity for the
community members to address the city council, and each speaker is allowed up
to 3 minutes. If you wish to speak during the public comment portion,
please complete the comment form located in the back of the room and return
it to our city recorder, Lacey, on this side.
Council members will listen but not engage in discussion during public comment.
We ask that everyone remain respectful.
Disruptive behavior, including cheering, booing, clapping, or comments directed
at individual city employees, is prohibited. If you have an issue or question regarding
staff or personnel, administrative staff will meet you in the foyer for further discussion.
Lastly, public comment period is for items not associated with
the scheduled public hearing. If your comment relates to a public hearing item,
please wait until that item is called. And tonight's public
hearing items are 16A, resolution and public hearing of Eagle
Mountain City approving the first amendment to the fiscal year 2026-2027
annual budget. So that one we will call in just a few minutes.
Right now I will open the public comment period at 7:16 and
ask if if there's anyone here. I do have Brianne Salazar.
She noted 16A but also wanted to comment on 17A.
16A is a public hearing.
OK, 16A we can wait, but 17A is fine.
Brianne Salazar.
We will allow you to come back again on 17, just so you know.
You get 3 minutes, but in the public hearing you'll you'll get a chance again.
So you will get a chance to speak again in '16.
Make sure the mic is on. There you go.
Okay, so I am Brianne Salazar.
So I just have a couple of questions,
and I know you can't answer my questions,
but the one question that I have is, one,
why do you think Do we pray?
Why do we not have a clear designation of church and state?
That is concerning to me as a non-prayerful
person. That is troubling. Second,
I just want to state that I hope or
would ask that we do not. approve the
property tax. And then I also
ask that we stop having data
centers come into Eagle Mountain. So as a resident
that's just further up towards city center,
I just ask that we stop having data centers come
in. So that's all that I have.
So thank you. Thank you.
So Joy Rasmussen as well, general comments, and then the public hearing comment
for 16A. Hello,
I'm here once again to ask, I heard the news that Meta is
building a bunch more data centers, and I'm not sure if those had been approved,
like, a long time ago, or that was just like a recent thing.
But the sentiment I'm hearing from everybody I know, most everybody, not everybody,
but most everybody, is they're very concerned about building more and more data
centers, that it's taking up so much land, and that's what we're going to be
known for. That's going to affect our property values. There's lots of— it's very unpopular
right now, data centers. And they're getting these deals
to not pay very much property tax, which doesn't feel fair
when you're raising it for us. And so I'm asking you again to
please issue like a resolution that you
will stop approving data centers until like
safety measures have been taken to protect us. Like there's a lot of talk about
AI being dangerous, and that's what these data centers are for. They're not for
like just going on Facebook. They're all doing AI. And there's a
lot of concerns about like the infrasound. So there's sound that you can't actually hear,
but your body feels. And it damages your heart, people living near them are
gonna be damaged by these data centers. It takes a bunch of energy,
and it just feels kind
of backwards to be raising our property taxes and giving these data centers the deals.
So maybe if you were like publicly disclosed all the deals and showed the citizens
like, hey, here's why they're benefiting us, like we've mentioned before, that might
be a better way to do it before you announce a bunch of new data
centers. Like, take citizens' input. And the second thing is
I'm going to ask that you repeal the property tax increase because,
um, we haven't been given the line-by-line budget numbers
properly. Um, the pamphlet is inaccurate that we were given by
the city. Um, the pamphlet says it would be on the ballot August 27— August
of 2027, but the code says it should be on this coming November election if
it gets enough signatures. So that's inaccurate. We've emailed the, the recorder
to ask you to correct the pamphlet. I'm asking you guys to respond to that
email and correct the— there's a lot of things that are inadequate or inaccurate according
to law. So that's all I have to say. Thank you.
Missy Perry.
Just kind of piggybacking off of Joy Rasmussen,
my name is Missy Perry. This is the first meeting
I've come to. I've I've lived here for about 6 years,
and I feel like you need to represent
the citizens and also listen to the concerns
that we have. And I find it incredibly concerning what has
been happening recently in our city.
I would like there to be a clear,
concise outline of the budget,
of the allocations of funds regarding our budget, and why the
property tax increase has occurred. I want that to be put
on the ballot to be voted on or either repealed
because citizens have a right to choose. This is affecting
my family. This is going to affect my future children. And I
just want to see on the budget, I want to see the proof of your
work. Where did you come up with this? What did you— did you look into
other budgets to cut things, to kind of cut
the fat to put money into other things to allocate
that to help with what we need for public safety.
Because I'm not against public safety or anything, even though that's been purported
like throughout the media. Like, that's— I want to support
the fact that we have an increased need for public,
um, like police or a couple more deputies and whatnot.
However, I want to see the proof of your work. I want to see
where on the budgets we couldn't cut things. So,
um, I want a line-by-line thing. I would like to see something similar
to what, um, Saratoga Springs has and what
they have shown their citizens. And I find it very concerning that every time
it's brought up, it's deleted from the city citizens page. It's deleted,
um, on all these different forums where usually
we all come together and It's just very concerning to me that this is
happening here in our town, and I'm
having to come here in person
and say, please just show me your work, show me the physical proof,
because the links that are provided are not adequate at all.
Thank you for your time.
I do want to clarify that she did also request 16A, so we'll come
back And that's all I have right now.
Okay, is there anyone else that is here that came to speak in
our public comment period that did not get
an opportunity? Seeing no one, we will close our public comment period at 7:23,
and we'll bring it back to the council. But I can answer a couple
of quick questions. Marcus can help me on some of this.
The question about the ballot. The county
required— they're already printing ballots. They get mailed out in a couple
of weeks. For us to say whether or not the referendum would be—
would have the signatures on the ballot, we don't know that answer yet.
So what the law actually says is that we can
hold a special election. Yeah, it says that it'll be held the next
regular municipal election, whichever is earlier, unless a special election is called.
So the intent would be to call a special election In the event it qualifies
for a ballot, right? There's no way to get it on the ballot because
we don't have the signatures yet, and it's already required to be into
the county right now. So given the signatures, it will be an item that
will be voted on. It'll just be voted on at the appropriate time with the
next election. I think that's
most of what I'm going to address right now. I'm happy to address any of
the other concerns or questions. After the meeting, so with that,
we'll bring it back to the council and Melissa Councilman
Clark. Thanks, Mayor. Thank you for being here tonight. It's fun to
see first responders and some of our residents coming and sharing their
thoughts about what's going on with the city and the questions that they have.
If I could, I would sit down with you each on your front porch and
talk to you about some of the decisions. decisions that we've made and help
you see just some of our reasons behind them.
So if you have questions, please reach out. It's very difficult to conduct
a conversation on Facebook with people. So,
um, that— I also want to thank our tiny,
tiny army of staff that has done so
many great things this summer with us. Between water
pipes busting and wells going down and having
to write and do huge packets and
to do the publicity and information
about different events and answer questions. And I
really wanted to acknowledge Evan Barrett. 10 years
ago, our city had an intern that thought
it would be a really cool idea to have a street fair so
that there would be a place for our small businesses to be able to go
and sell what they make to our neighbors.
And that street fair grew to the point where it didn't fit on the street
anymore. And it was really, really cool. We liked
that street because it was shaded and there were lots of trees there.
But this weekend That street fair celebrated
its 10th anniversary, and, um, none of that would have happened
without Evan Barrett's dedication and foresight and
drive to help support our small businesses in our community.
And Evan, I just want to thank you for all that you've done to help
economic development and our small businesses. So thank you.
Thanks, Mayor. Welcome. It's good to see so many who've come
out tonight. Just want to express my gratitude to each of you for taking
the time to come and to share your thoughts. Even if we have a difference
of opinion or we understand things perhaps from a little different perspective,
I'm always grateful to, to have those who see things
differently to help me see things from a different perspective.
I want to, uh, I, I want to, I want to highlight Mayor Gray.
He's not expecting this, He doesn't know this. I'm probably going to embarrass him,
and I'm going to do it on purpose, okay?
I just want to express my gratitude for the work that he has been doing.
He has been running around Utah.
He's been running around the nation and meeting with anybody
and everybody whose ear he can get to try and help
us advance those things that matter to Eagle Mountain. Citizens.
He spent some time— and look,
I know there are some who will say, well, gosh, why are you doing
that? We're doing it because we're trying to improve our situation. I know
he's met with Senator Curtis, with Congressman Kennedy.
Certainly he met with the Speaker of the House today, Mike Schultz, and he's talked
with Stuart Adams, our Senate President, worked with our local
representatives, both House and Senate. And I just,
I don't think the citizens really see the work that goes
into what our mayor does. He's a cowboy at
heart. He's used to getting up at 4:00 AM and taking clients
on a hunt. And he works hard all day.
He rides his horse, which anybody that's ridden a horse knows how
much fun that is or isn't. I don't
do it, can't do it. Some of you here do and enjoy that.
But I just, I wish that each of you could spend 24
hours with him and just see the effort that he's putting forth on your
behalf. I think that the way you feel about him and perhaps this council would
start to change and modify a little bit if you really understood the
work that we are about. So thank you, Mayor Gray, for your
leadership, your example, and for your advocacy. advocacy, and in
spite of your many imperfections, which are
smaller than mine, I just am grateful for you and
for the efforts you've been putting forward.
Thank you for those who made public comment. One invitation
I'll extend is I'm very happy to meet with any of you who have concerns
or questions that were brought up. It would be a lot easier to to
go through and answer the questions in person,
on Zoom, whatever, live. It'd be a lot easier than
in an email or text messaging or definitely, or like
instant messaging, whatever it may be. And I've extended that invitation to any who's had
questions. Some residents have taken the opportunity to meet with me.
And those of you who presented today, I'm happy to meet with you as well
to ensure that your questions are all answered. and that
understanding could be provided back and forth.
So I'm very happy to listen and to share
what I can. So just reach out to me individually. I'm happy to set up
a private, or you can make it public if you want to bring people as
well, that's fine. I'm happy to meet with whoever you wanna meet with, so,
or have come and join on that. Grateful to be part of this great city.
And, you know, we,
This city has significant opportunity,
and in many ways there's a
blank canvas before us more than any other kind of city that's here in Utah.
And so with that, there comes great responsibility that we guide it in
a way that it becomes a prosperous city for all,
not just for a few, but for all. And as a council, we feel the
burden to make sure that the way we develop the city and grow
it and and nurture it,
it's done in a way that is with a lot of foresight and
that we are contemplative of the various opportunities
and to make sure we execute those in the best way possible to bring the
greatest amount of prosperity possible to the greatest amount of people.
It's really our endeavor as a council. We dive
into the details. We research. We struggle,
we debate back and forth, we listen to a lot of people.
One thing that's opened my eyes is before
I got elected, I was warned that it was going to take quite a bit
of time. The warnings were not strong enough. It takes a lot of time,
a lot more time than I anticipated, and it's weightier
than I anticipated. It's also very rewarding. It's also
very challenging. Thank you. But it's weighty because
we are trying to do something that has not been done. We are trying to
create something that has not been created, and we're trying to elevate this city to
a place that no one thought it could go.
It's going to take a lot of energy and drive to do that. I can
tell you that as what Councilmember Wright just said about our mayor,
that it's true. Mayor Gray is leading from the front,
and it's also true that we are We endeavor to take this city to a
place that no one thought it could ever go. When I say we, it's not
just the City Council. The staff is on board with this,
and citizens.
We're grateful for public participation,
public input, and ideas that come from the citizenry.
Your ideas will help us be stronger and better. I can tell you we are
going to go places that no one thought we could go. We will accomplish things
that people thought could never be accomplished, because we're going to think
larger than other people have thought. I'm grateful that we can be a part of
this great society that is and will be.
Thank you. It's my privilege to have a little bit of time, so I'll save
it for this. I will say that it's a lot more time than
we expected. I know the Morandis are here tonight. I used to ride horses every
Monday and Wednesday. Since I've been elected. I think I've been twice,
but I only remember once. So they can attest
that my riding has been on the back burner.
Going back to— I saved this for the personal time— to some of the questions.
I just want to say this the way that I say it every time.
Before I open the meeting, I say, as is
our tradition, we'll start with a prayer. Then I call
the meeting to order. That's before the meeting. It's something that happens before we start.
And that's by design. So I wanted to
answer that question. The other thing about the line-by-line
budget and stuff like that, I mean, Craig just told you
the hundreds and hundreds of hours that are recorded and posted.
And you're welcome to look at it. We try to answer every question we
can individually. I'm not saying that. We answer the best we can. They're posted in
300 pages of books that we've attached to the website.
I mean, we have done our best to show everything
we can in the budget, and we'll continue to do that.
A lot of citizens tell us, I don't want to read 300 pages and go
to thousands of hours of meetings. I expect you guys to do it.
That's what we've done. Thank you. happy to sit down
and go through every bit of why and how and what we
arrived at and discuss that, because I think that's the other part
of our job, is helping others understand the Cliff Notes version of
why we did what we did. And that will help us all get
to a better place and a better understanding. Just to
add to some of the other things, I'm grateful for Shop Fest,
the way that went off. I spent a few hours there in the morning before
I had to go to some other things. And then also the farmer's market that
for 3 years in a row, I think I haven't been to everyone, but I've
been to a lot of farmer's markets the last 3 years. And it, man,
it has grown this year. It is unreal how big.
And all the vendors are saying the best market around. They go to other markets
and they're like, we go to Eagle Mountain and some of the others, but they
love this one. So great opportunities in our city. And a lot of
that to our staff. Evan started some of those ideas and we appreciate those going
forward as well as, I mean, the park staff that's shown up
this year. The market's been amazing thanks to those guys every Saturday coming in.
The other thing you mentioned, the Rotary stuff,
with that, the reason that's happening is it's homecoming week.
So just a special highlight with our kids at the high school. Be watching
out at the restaurants, they're probably going to be all dressed up. But the homecoming
game Friday night, if you get a chance to come out, I'm going to go.
I've been a couple of football games already. It's super fun. Just love supporting those
kids. So just remember some of those other
activities that are out there. But we appreciate you guys coming and helping us
with perspective and being part of the process. It really is— it takes
all of us. And I can't wait until I get to sit back down there
and maybe start riding on Mondays again. So welcome to
run and come and do this job. It's a lot of work. So thank you.
Thank you. Thank you for being a part of it. With that,
we have a few items in our consent agenda. I hope you guys made notes
'cause I know there's a couple changes, but we did talk
about most of these. There was the 14B,
right, had a change, and then I thought there was one more
in— It was just the one. Which one? I think that's
it. Okay, okay, with that then, Unless there's discussion,
will entertain a motion. Mayor, I, uh, I move that the Eagle Mountain City Council
approve the consent agenda, uh, and on item
14B include the Planning Commission's recommendation
number 2 only. Second.
Okay, we have a motion by Councilman Wright and a second by Councilmember Whiting,
and we'll start the vote with Councilman Wright. Yes. Councilman Whiting. Yes.
Councilmember Clark. Yes. And just to be sure, Council Member Wood is not
online. Okay, that passes 3 to 0.
And we'll go on to our first scheduled item, item 16A,
resolution— and this is a public hearing— of Eagle Mountain City approving
the first amendment of the fiscal year 2026-2027 annual budget.
Uh, I do know that Terrence has a, a presentation to go
over some of the budget amendments. These are some of the things that we do
go over line by line And he's going to show us some of the things
that we've updated in our budget.
Good evening, Mayor and Council. As mentioned, I'll be going over the first
budget amendment for this current fiscal year. In your packet,
this is the information that you're Currently, it's in the packet,
but as discussed in the work session this afternoon,
there will be some few items that we're adding to the budget amendment.
I'll go them quickly and then we can talk about them in details later on.
The first one is some leftover rollover amount for the Eagle Monument Project,
digital display, wildlife corridor fencing
project, and then we have some transportation project,
widening Pony Express on the south side of the area, the Phase
1 from Eagle Mountain Boulevard to Shadow Drive,
and then from Shadow Drive to Public
Works area, and then some improvements in the Silver Lake
area as well. Um,
I want to provide some context on the requests that we received
for the budget amendment. I'm looking at it capital projects
versus operational budget requests. Majority of the requests,
and especially for this first budget amendment where we just end our
fiscal year '26 and we're rolling over to a new fiscal year,
um, as you know, projects tend to span multiple, uh,
fiscal years. So majority of these requests are related to
capital projects, and then about 7% are related to operational,
um, budget requests. If we're looking at capital
projects, um, About 89% are strictly rollovers,
so that means those are previously been approved as part
of the fiscal year 2026 budget. We're just rolling them over, whatever is the leftover,
to continue with the project in this current fiscal year. And then there's about
11% for the new capital project funding
requests, which I will go over in a bit.
Now looking at operational budget
requests, Majority of the requests are tied to vehicles.
As you know, a part of our current fiscal year has approved
some new personnel requests, and then they will need
some vehicles, so we need to purchase those for those individuals.
And then next is equipment. There are quite a few departments
that have requested some equipments that they need, which we, um,
probably using some of the one-time money from the reserves that we
can use for this one. The community development is requesting for
a software to help with their plan reviews,
and then there are some IFA or impact fee analysis,
some airport feasibility study that we need to roll
over as part of professional studies.
We also have one personal request in the general
fund. I'll go over that later. And then we have a couple of programs.
We have some rebate money that we receive for our premiums, which we
can use for some safety-related initiatives for the city and for
our employee. And then one of those programs is tied to the
soccer program, which we started this fall. And then the tiny,
tiny blue bar over there is for the office rental
space for the water department, the trailer mobile office.
Now I'll be going over the items fund
by fund. First is the general fund.
The general fund net change budget request,
about $1.4 million. Some of the rollover
items, as mentioned, we started our soccer
program this fall, and then we're— our recreation department is running that program.
So we just want to roll over those approved budget last fiscal year.
Economic Development has some airport feasibility study that they're doing as
well. In terms of new items, as mentioned,
there are some equipment requests from the streets, parks, and open space.
Comes from skid steer— skid steers to some
attachments, some large containers that we can put in the parks
as well. As mentioned, majority of requests are tied
to vehicles. And that rebate money that I mentioned about safety
initiatives that we get from that premium firm
rebate stuff. And as mentioned, we have one personal
request, which is to add a new deputy city recorder to help with
the workload in that department. Any questions about general fund?
And the biggest is the capital project fund.
So, um, some of the rollover items are
some improvement in Nolan Park Bike Park.
We're currently doing the Quarry Ride parking lot and,
um, some money for Pony Express Regional Park,
Silver Lake Community Park, and then, um, a street
or a transportation project, Silver Lake and Woodhaven Right Turn Lane Project,
that was previously, um, approved. And in terms of new funding,
um, there is grant money that we'll be receiving for
the new asphalt trail from Walden Park to
Cedar Corners, and, um, also some
sidewalk widening on Golden Eagle near Brookhaven
Elementary School. And then as part of
our discussion this work session, these are
some of the few items that are being requested. These items are for rollovers
as well. Eagle Monument, about $6,000,
$7,000. Digital info display, about $268,000.
And then wildlife corridor fencing, which is the grant money that we
received through the Division of Wildlife Resources, about $200,000.
And some transportation items are, as mentioned,
some widening in the Pony Express area. This is for construction that
is planned for February 2027. The,
um, budget requested is $1.8 million.
Um, it will be 2 to— for 2 to 5 lanes and removing that median.
Um, so this one is from Eagle Mountain Boulevard to Shadow Drive.
And then for Phase 2, um, they're requesting a,
a design money or funding for $250,000
that will be, uh, hopefully be done this fall 2026,
looking into between 3 to 5 lanes,
putting some traffic signals at Parkway Fields
and Paul Canyon Boulevard, and also realigning Paul Canyon Boulevard and
Pony Express intersection. And then some
improvement in Silver Lake neighborhood about
those roundabouts in Woodhaven and Silver Lake and Golden Eagle and Silver
Lake areas. It's $250,000.
It's— the plan is for this fall of 2026,
replacing them with traffic signals and also realignment of roads
and crosswalks. Any questions
about capital projects fund?
So if we— I mean, I know we have the speed study that's happening right
now. We're going to get the results here pretty soon. There's going to be Money
that we're gonna need to help execute that? We're gonna
just have to reallocate from the currently planned
capital projects? Is that what we'll have to do in order to fund that?
I think part of the plan is to, as part of our retreat, that will
cover some of discussion about capital projects. So right now, once we
roll over some of this money, I think there is a $200,000 that is already
budgeted, which is not enough. And then
when we do the retreat and we can discuss all these capital projects,
and then we can figure out the priorities and then reevaluate,
and then we can reallocate some of this funding.
Any other questions for capital projects? I have one question. The trailer rental
that you referenced. Yes.
I'm just curious why we're not buying a trailer. I guess that's the thing
that's been banging around in my head is why are we renting one instead
of just buying one? That's a good question.
I don't know if Brad or Mack can help me with this one.
I don't have a solid answer for you today. I just,
I mean, it's how we've done it. It's been a rental trailer since It's
existed there. I think it's probably been there 2,
3 years. And so— We just keep renting it. And I'm just thinking— It's
something we can definitely look into. If we're renting it year after year, why aren't
we just buying it if we need it? Here comes the answer.
Yeah, this has been a temporary solution as we try to get the funding
mechanism in place for the admin building. So this
will be a part of this project that we're underway Okay.
Our hopes was to do that building first, but with funding and whatnot,
I didn't— I mean, what's that look— what's that timetable looking like? 3 years?
Yeah, we're tracking like a 3-year window on that. So, Mac, maybe you should come
back up. So, I mean, if— so if, if, if we can
see, if it's foreseeable that we're going to be using this trailer for
the next 3 years, why aren't we buying it? Or what does it cost us
a year? my understanding, these things are not cheap, and the, the rate that
we're paying, we'd have to have it for probably another 7 years to
break even. But that'd be a question that we could ask Jeff,
as he was the original facilitator of this.
Do we— what's the— you're asking what the lease rate is, right? Do we know
what our lease payment is on that? It's, uh, $18,000 a year.
$18,000? $18,000. Oh, $18,000.
But it is fully furnished.
Yeah, for me, that's, that's just one— that's the, the thing that stuck out to
me is I thought, man, why aren't we just purchasing this? And I know
that one of the solutions too that we've talked a lot about is the North
Service Area, and, and maybe we could put a trailer up there in the meantime,
but hopefully that's less than 7 years. Potentially a
City Hall, less than 5.
Originally, it was hoped, and this might have led to this, originally it was hoped
that we would do the admin building first. But because of the cost of
the overall sewer treatment plant, we want to make sure that we have the wiggle
room and have the administration building at the end to make sure that we have
everything that we need to take care of the citizens' needs with sewer processing and
then use the rest for the administration building.
It's all timing. What does
Kimberly say? It's all the Yeah,
you know, I guess I don't have any major concerns about it. I just,
I just wondered if we'd been down that path with that one item.
We can look into it.
Any other questions on the presentation before we go to public comment?
I just need to finish a couple more, sir. Mayor, you're right, I'm doing 5
by 5. I can finish them up and then we'll do the questions later,
if that's okay. Thank you, Mayor. So the next one will be special revenue
fund. Mostly these are related to the IFA study,
the impact fee analysis for water, wastewater, stormwater,
transportation, parks and trails. The new items being requested
is the software, as I mentioned, that community development looking for plan
reviews, and also some contractual agreement for
the White Hills well water line project. For Enterprise
Fund, we're rolling over some of the water
and wastewater projects: well number 9, well number 7,
the 4 million gallon tank in City Center, well number
8. When it comes to tied to the wastewater
treatment plant project, the Ox Ditch upgrade, then we have Type 1
tertiary Treatment, and of course our 6 MGD
wastewater treatment plan. In terms of new items
being requested, there are some equipment requested
by these departments for water and stormwater, which included in the
budget amendment. And then also there are some additional funding needed for Well
Number 5 upgrade. This includes updating the electrical
control panel, the switchgear, and some PLC items for
that, um, well project. Any questions for
the rest of the items?
I, I just have a question for Ben. Ben, you gave us an update on
well number 9 that they're at 1,000 feet plus or minus.
That surprised me, meaning they're moving along pretty well with
that. Is that going to come online for some of these others that we've had
trouble with. I see Brad raising his hand and
Max coming up to speak to it, but we have a
very good, experienced well driller, and so we're very
pleased with their progress. Yeah, so they're at roughly 1,300
feet. Yeah,
they're cruising. They're anticipating this being wrapped up by the end of tomorrow as far
as the drilling, and then they'll start the process of What
does that mean for timing, Mac? I mean, what do you think? I mean,
timing, we're probably another 45 days from wrapping
that up. We'll have to do a test pump. Once we get that reviewed,
then we'll go into design. So we're probably another year
before that's operational. We're just
trying to improve the average from wells 7 and 8 and having
9 all come together too. a consistent average. But Ben, that's why I
asked, because having had the experience with 7 and 8 and what a miserable
experience that's been, frankly, and at 7 in particular,
right? And our residents don't know all that story,
but seeing that number 9 is going the way it is, I'm thinking maybe
that will develop quicker on a shorter timeline than what we've been dealing with 7
and 8. That's hopeful. I also
think that there's some other components just for record too. So Well 9,
obviously we'll have to test pump it to see what it is so that we
can design the well house and all the motors and everything. But there's also
the conveyance, the water lines, the water system that we need to connect into it
as well. And so those are future projects that are on the capital project
plan that we'll have to facilitate, and they'll have to be built in
conjunction with that. Coming online. So yeah, within the
next couple years. So yes, just for context.
Yeah, that, that well was done in less than a year,
and the other one's been 5 years and still not done. It's pretty impressive.
So any other comments on that?
All right, seeing none,
we will open the public hearing at 7:51 and
Look to Lacey. I know there's a few.
Brianne Salazar.
Okay, so my question was, um,
At least in terms of the vehicles, um,
why are vehicles not,
um, kept at the facility?
Um, why are vehicles allowed,
specifically like police vehicles,
um, uh, park vehicles,
um, not kept here, um,
at the main Like City Hall.
Why are they allowed to be taken back and forth?
If you go to other states— I'm from back east— police
vehicles stay at the stations.
Police officers arrive to work, get their vehicle,
and then take it out for service,
go back to the office, get their, their car, and then
go home. That extra additional mileage,
and if the officer is not required to live in that county,
they're adding on additional mileage that's not needed,
damage to the vehicle that's not needed, you know,
all that additional extra wear and tear on the vehicle that is completely
not needed unless the officer is required
to live in Utah County or at least within Eagle Mountain,
which I don't think that they are.
So that is a lot of extra money that we
are having to spend on vehicles that
don't really need to be taken, one,
out of the jurisdiction or out of the
area. So that's something to look into.
And then the other thing is the transportation bid.
Um, is this the best bid
that was reviewed and received? Um,
$250,000 just for a design,
um, seems really high just for
showing what we're going to do for a 3
to 5 lane. I mean, call me crazy, but it's a
straight line. Um, and then
for the additional things for the parks, um, are all of those things absolutely
necessary to do right now during this fiscal year?
Um, I think it was— 30 seconds remaining. Talked about previously to add some
ADA things, but any of the additional things,
are they absolutely necessary to do now?
If not, Wait. Thank you.
Joy Rasmussen.
So I'm going to ask that you not pass this budget because
when you were showing the slides up there with where things are going for
what projects, there was no dollar amounts listed. So we couldn't, like, add it up
and see if there's something else being funded that's not being shown to us,
like the admin building. I'm wondering what this admin building is. Is that by chance
the new city hall that you already bought land for and hired an architect to
do a study on that? Because I
just feel like there's not enough details here for the citizens,
and I think you could look at your budget and cut some things out so
you don't have to do the property tax increase. So I'm asking that you don't
pass it. Also, the requirement
for the pamphlet for the referendum requires
a fiscal and legal impact statement that should identify all funding sources
for the estimated cost. This is off topic.
She needs to stay on topic to the public hearing.
Okay, yeah, I would ask that you not pass the budget because there's not enough
details. Citizens have lots of concerns, they're paying a lot more attention, and there weren't
enough details up there. We can't sit here and do the math and make sure
that what you're saying you need is going to just those things and not something
else that hasn't been revealed. Thank you.
Missy Perry.
Hello again. So I was kind of pondering some
things while he was giving the presentation regarding the
budget and the different things that are like being added.
And to be honest, a few of them kind of raised my eyebrows a little
bit. And I can't help but think that this
is similar to like a shopping list of items. Right? You guys are going
through like, okay, we have parks, we have vehicles,
we have all of these different things that need additional funding
or that we can like put into like,
um, projects and whatnot. However,
when times are tough and things like are
a bit tumultuous, which I feel like we're kind of going into a
big change with the transition from Alpine School District
to the Westlake School District and everything that's gonna be happening in 2027.
Those are also things that are gonna be coming forth. And I feel
like when that happens, you need to start cutting things from
your wishlist, from your grocery list of, okay,
what do we need to keep? Obviously meat and vegetables are necessary.
Maybe we can skip on the dessert this year. Maybe that's something
that we can hold off on a year or two. Maybe we don't
change roundabouts into more lights. Maybe there's a
better way to use the roundabout. Maybe if we actually paint
them and properly sign them, maybe expand them,
they could be utilized correctly. And actually, they're better.
Roundabouts are better on traffic and congestion if
they're used properly. And you don't have to put up
a light. You save $250,000. And you don't have to run
electric to a currently existing roundabout. Maybe just widen it a bit,
add proper lines so people can see the lines and know how
to navigate through them correctly. But that is a big— that's another item
that could save us some money to help cut the cost
from having to put taxes on citizens for
their property. That money could then go— instead of property taxes
increasing, we could use These funds are things that we
push off for a different day or a different year that aren't necessary,
that aren't— we have to have these right now. It's the things that are
needed. Absolutely, we need public safety,
we need less congestion on the roads, but there
are some things that I think if we think about it— 10 seconds
remaining. You can come up with a better idea than
just ripping it out and putting in a light or just
adding things to parks. Maybe we just wait on that
until things are a bit more stable. Thank you.
I'd like to thank the residents for, for the, the questions and concerns that
you've brought up. We do want to make sure that we're addressing those. And so
if I've asked the mayor if I could take just a minute to maybe answer
a few of those questions, and maybe I'll go backwards Just hang on,
Ben. I just want to make sure that everyone's done. I don't know if you
meant to wait till the end, so I didn't know if you had a specific
comment. Are you— we're good? I have nothing else. Okay. Is there anyone else that
came to speak on this item that did not get an opportunity?
Okay, seeing none, I'll close the public hearing at 8 o'clock.
And, uh, go ahead. Thank you, Mayor. Um, so first of
all, I just want to address some of the things that, that were brought up.
As far as traffic safety improvements and things like that,
we do have a responsibility to ensure that we provide
the best possible safety to our residents and that we
do so using engineering standards and that we follow
those standards through studies. And part
of that is ensuring that we don't have intersections that fail. And so when we
have an intersection like right out here here, um, where it's not
a roundabout, it's a, a light at, at Trailhead and Pony
Express where it is failing and there is a safety hazard, um,
that's where those type of improvements go forward. And so,
um, those type of studies are needed in order for us to move forward,
and we also need those type of studies so we can have cost estimates to
be able to, um, plan for in our budgeting process.
Um, as far as, um, the budget amendment,
this isn't the budget, this is an amendment to the budget. And as
Terrence has reviewed, most of the things that were in this—
and I, I believe it was close to 90% or more than 90%— are
items that are carryover projects that are currently funded with current
contractors and everything on board. And so what we're doing is
we're taking the funding that was approved last year— because the project has spanned,
uh, fiscal years— it is moving that money so that it can be spent
this year, and we can fulfill those contractual obligations. Otherwise, we would
just leave those projects undone throughout our community. We have to complete
those projects, and we cannot spend money unless it's been
approved by our elected leaders. There was a
question with regard to the administration building. This is not the new City Hall.
Our new sewer treatment plant has a planned administration
building for the sewer department personnel
that would be operating that facility. facility or doing the collection system for our entire
city. And part of that sewer treatment plant
envisions an office building. We just want to make sure that we can afford
the processing portion of it before putting in the actual building portion, because if
there's something that needs to be cut, it would be the building, not the processing.
That's the most essential component. But it is not a new city
hall. You also— And I think that's a good
point. You know, I mean, what can we cut? What can we tighten?
We're literally— didn't we just hear that we're in a trailer?
Exactly. We are currently— And paying rent on a trailer. And paying rent. I mean,
it's literally exactly what we've been doing. And as
we move forward, if we can afford an
admin building, it would replace that trailer. And like Brett said,
we hate renting. Owning is way cheaper,
and that's part of that construction of a new sewer treatment plant. We've got a
bunch of employees. That plant doesn't run itself, correct?
Uh, and we're currently in a trailer. That— and by the way, that's been 16
years of no— of cutting,
correct? Um, the last thing I wanted to address was, um, the take-home
vehicle question and the police vehicles and on-call vehicles and whatnot. Now,
every city employee has a vehicle that they take home. It is those
employees who are on call or would have responsibilities to
come out during an emergency or during a fire, during like as far as
building inspection, a water break.
And we have those at all hours of the day and night. And when we
have an emergency need, our person— Every hour of the day.
Yeah, exactly. Every time there's an emergency, we have
to have personnel that can respond with the tools that they need to be able
to immediately provide benefit to the residents
incidents and not drive all the way back down to the Public Works building,
which is on the south end of our city. If that problem— let's say
they live in the ranches or they even live in Saratoga, they'd have to drive
all the way to past City Center near the data centers
where our Public Works facility is and drive all the way back in order to
respond. And homes could be damaged, water could be
lost, all sorts of problems could take place if our personnel
didn't have the on-call vehicles with the tools they need to do the job effectively
for the safety of our residents. Specifically, it was talked about with
public safety and police officers. Of course, the Sheriff's Department
is separate and they have their own policies when it comes to that. But having
been a city manager in both Utah County, outside of Utah County,
and in the entire nation, I can tell you that on-call
vehicles or police officers across the nation, typically the standard
is that they do take their vehicles home, and that is especially held
true in the state of Utah. I'm from New York. I lived— I've worked in
Iowa. I've worked in other places. The reason that
police officers, especially in the state of Utah, take their vehicles home is because
the prevailing feeling is that police vehicles on the road
create a sense of safety and stability, even if they're in the commute mode.
And having those vehicles out out and about instills safety so that people drive
better, they're more cognizant of what's going on, and there's more security.
And if an officer actually did need to respond and they were off duty,
they would have the tools and equipment that they need to be able to respond
as well. This is so much so in the United States
that the difference between regular take-home vehicles and police
department take-home vehicles is that the IRS requires
that if a take-home vehicle goes home, let's say, with somebody who's on
call, that commute time is actually a taxable
benefit to that employee. And that taxable benefit goes on
their paycheck and whatnot, and they're responsible for that— those miles and the
fuel that they would use in their commute time. But police vehicles
are exempt from that by IRS standards, and that is because of
the overall greater good of having police vehicles on the street. And so police
officers, sheriff's department deputies, they are not taxed
for their commute because they could be called upon to respond at any time for
any emergency anywhere in the state. And they're all licensed by
post throughout the entire state. And so it's not just a jurisdictional
thing. They could respond anywhere. So I just wanted to answer some of those questions.
Hopefully I've hit them all. There's a couple more I can touch on,
but also just On that vehicle one, why are
they not here? Because they're parked at our Public Works. We have limited stalls.
We barely have enough spaces. But we do have several that are parked here.
And we do have some that are here. And then also on the sheriff
ones, even though it's a need, newsflash, we pay
$9.8 million no matter where they park because we're on contract. So it doesn't
save us or cost us. It's absolutely a set price. And I don't care
where you drive that car because it doesn't cost me any money. But these were
all good questions, and we're glad that you asked them so we could answer them
for the entire public. Yeah, yeah, so that's— Mayor?
Yeah. I think there was one more, and I think it stems from what you
use the money for. There was kind of this parallel idea
of like maybe a family budget and going grocery shopping and
getting the extras or the fluff. And I think a lot of people see the
parks as The difference between a
family budget and the city budget is there
are certain funds that can only be used for certain things.
And when there's parks funds that come from parks impact fees, we can't
just shift those over and use them for water or sewer or
for an additional employee or anything like that. They have to very specifically
be used according to state law for the things that
they were collected for. for. So while, um,
I had the same question before I ran for office, I was like, why are
we spending money on Corey Ride Park? Um, and before
it was built. And I, I think that it's helpful to understand
the legal limitations of certain dollars within
a municipal budget. I, I think that is a really good point. And I maybe
just to add on to that as well, um, we do have certain assets in
our community, and we want to make, make sure that we take care of and
maintain those. It's our responsibility. Those are your assets, and we want
to make sure we preserve them. And, um, to not take care of some of
those assets would be equivalent to you not changing the oil in your car.
Um, it might get you by, and you might not be able to— you might
be able to live for a period of time, but eventually you're going to have
to replace that engine. And so we want to make sure that we maintain
our assets to the very best of our ability for our residents. And yet our
level of service is really strained because we're spread very, very thin. And that's why
the council's looking to bring more staff on to be able to help with
enhancing our parks and open spaces. Can you also address
how it costs $250,000 to engineer something?
That's the last thing that I was waiting to get on right here. Yeah,
and do you— and what's the process of determining you're going to choose that particular
engineer? So we do have a procurement process, first of all, and this is something
that I did for a living. Not the procurement, but the actual construction.
And when we say design a road, you know, for $200,000,
first of all, the $250,000, we had talked about this earlier today and we
think it's going to be 70% of that. But this is a budget amount.
This is what we're putting in the budget so that we can make sure that
we can get the job done. Doesn't mean that's what it's going to cost.
Doesn't mean that's the bid amount. That's how much we have in our budget to
make sure that we get the job done. We think that that design's probably
closer to $200,000. But what that covers is engineering
for road base and inspections and the water
line and the sewer line. It's not just the surface that you see. It's everything
underneath it and designing everything
from the roads, the curves. I'm sure you want to weigh in, so I'm just
going to let you go ahead. Sure. And so there's other things too. There's also
signal I mean, you know, conduits, controls, being that they're— it's more complicated than
that, especially when you widen a road. You also have to get, you know,
on-site survey as well as look at the elevations, because roads aren't actually flat,
they're actually curved. If they were flat, we would have water standing on there and
you wouldn't be able to drive on it. So we have to look at what's
the curvature of the existing road, make sure we match it so it drains properly,
we don't have standing water out there. So then that drain is going to
go into the storm drain pipe that's actually underground. Yeah,
where does that water go once we design that? It can't have a belly in
it or it's no longer going to— it has to go downhill and then it's
got to be pumped up and it's got to go downhill, right? That's all design.
The size of the pump, how much water— if it's 7 lanes
wide as opposed to 2 lanes wide, how much surface is that in
a 100-year storm? Can that pipe hold it? That's a lot of math. How many
hours is that? It's a lot.
It's a lot of hours. So a lot of engineers, there's site surveys, verification.
I would just like to add to the point of this is that not only
do we comply with state procurement laws, we comply with
our own city procurement laws and responsibilities, our codes, to make
sure that we advertise properly, that we receive
bids from all competent contractors,
that we go through evaluation process, a scoring process. It's very
regimented. We have a purchasing person. We're going to be bringing
on another because we have so many projects, but it just doesn't include that one
purchasing person. Depending upon the project, if it's streets or
if it's parks or water or whatever, we have a whole group that score
those things out. And it's not necessarily always the lowest bid,
I will admit that. It is the greatest value
to the city, and we have to look at that based on their
qualifications, what work they've performed in the past. You know, if someone right out of
college versus somebody who's done a sewer treatment project
of 6 million gallons per day before, and that they have proven
competence to be able to do that. We want to make sure that we have
the right people on the job and that we're using the taxpayers' resources to the
very best of our ability. We consider those dollars to be exceptionally
important and, and, and, and treat those with the greatest of
respect. And typically that does land on the lowest bid a lot of times.
A lot of times they are. A lot of times, sometimes they're qualification-based
as well. Yep. So, all right, I think we've answered most of those questions.
And again, we're happy to speak to anyone. You know, one thing
we're trying to do is make sure that the information is out there because the
last thing we want is to leave that unanswered. So if we didn't answer something,
by all means, we've all posted our phone numbers and we love
talking to residents to help you understand why we're where we're at. There's one more
question that didn't get answered. So it was brought up that the presentation that Terrence
did did not itemize the expenses, but if
you, if you go to the public agenda, it itemizes every single
item. So if you go to eaglemountain.gov, you click
on public meetings, you go click on the public meetings portal,
and then you click on today's meeting, which it'll scan right
down to it. You click on today's meeting, you click on the agenda item,
And you'll see a budget worksheet that itemizes everything line
by line by line. And that's also in your packet, so you've already studied it,
so this was more of a highlight, correct? Right, and the presentation that Terrence
did was more of a, it was not intended to go line
by line by line by line on everything. He was sort of hitting some highlights
that gave us an opportunity to ask questions, but we've been given this
line by line by line by line in advance so we could read through it.
So we could give Terrence questions, but it's there for
anybody to see. It's there for the public to see. It was not hidden.
And then the other thing I will say, so when it comes to a city
hall, because this has been brought up a lot,
it's a long process to build a city hall.
And you have to, you've got to buy the land and you got to design
and it takes, you can't just do it all at the same time. So you
just, Budget for it slowly, year by year by year, by completing step after
step after step. So are we progressing down steps? Yes,
because we need to. And if you look at other cities our size, they have
city halls, and we're living in rented trailers.
And and I would invite you to talk to our staff and ask them.
Do your own independent analysis. Ask the staff if we have enough space.
Don't just trust what we have researched. Go ask them. I'm gonna say
something on that real quick. Quick if you want, because this just came up today.
Fly a drone, go take a picture of this building and look at the square
footage of this building. From where we're sitting, everything on this side of us is
the library. There's no staff in there. This is the council chamber we use for
planning commission. We use it every single day for trainings, for meetings.
We have the sheriff's department in this quarter of the building
on this side. We have over 200 employees, but I'll call it 180
employees roughly, and that's over 200 now, that are in
that quarter of the building, which has about— and
plus 3/4 office, which is 4 more employees.
9 offices for 200 employees. That's it.
Well, you've got that in addition to the Public Works building. Yeah, but I mean,
here, and, and the rent office space that we rent on our north end of
town, all rented, and you can own any of the vehicles Cars parked outside of
there every night. All rented, and there's not enough space over there.
Here in this building, we have 9 offices for all of
our— that we could put in one building, be more efficient, and save a
ton of money. When we have a meeting here, and this is— I think the
residents don't understand this about the City Hall. It's not because I want— when the
City Hall gets built, I'll never see it. I'm building this— it's like plant
a tree for somebody, for shade for somebody else. I'll never enjoy the shade of
that building. The problem is when we have a meeting here
and Steve needs to come from that building and Brad needs to come from this
building, and we spend hours of wasted time
coming to a meeting where we could be in the same building and have our—
get our work done and go to work and get more accomplished. We will save
money building a city hall. I will advocate for a city hall
all day long that I will never sit in because it is the right thing
to do and we need it. Our city is way overgrown
for this building. It's not even close. So, you know, I mean,
I'll have that conversation all day long. A city hall is
not a want, it is a need, 100%.
And I will advocate for that every day,
even if I never sit in it. So that's
the city hall. I kind of cut you off, Craig. I want to make sure—
No, it's all right. You took my thunder and ran with it, and you did
a great job with it. Because I think the number's important. We got like 9
buildings or 9 offices. Well, to your point, and you said it,
like, we're doing something that I'm not gonna— this is gonna
be completed after our terms are done. And this is a lot of decisions
we're making, and that's why I made the public comment earlier today. We're making decisions
today to benefit the future. This is not benefiting us specifically.
And another thing that I wrote down, I was just gonna let it go,
but 99% of this— I can't
reach back there. Will you pat my back a little bit? Because you already did
earlier today. None of this is funded with tax dollars.
Most of this is money that we've gone out and got from MAG,
from other partners, from federal appropriations,
from the state. Today we were talking about $600 million,
$700 million, $800 million today.
$500 million on the one road and $300 million
with the extension of Mountain View, that I went up there and
spent the whole day advocating for, that I think we just moved up 15 years.
Wait, I can't reach again. I'm just kidding. It's not
taxpayer money. But I think this is, this is the point, Mayor.
I mean, this is something that I think our residents completely miss.
Property taxes last year raised $2.8 million in Eagle Mountain city,
period, across the board. That's all taxpayers.
$2.8 million. Every single thing we touch,
every project we touch is well in advance of $2.8 million.
A well costs us $7 or $8 million to put in. So it's
not coming from property taxes. I, I just,
I just think that we miss that, and I think it's important that we underline
that even with an increase of 60 67%
or 69%, that number still is
only going to go to somewhere around— $4.5 million.
$4.5 million, which is, which is a truckload
of money if it's in my bank account. In the city's coffers,
$4.5 million is a drop in the bucket and will fund
perhaps one small section of road improvement.
I mean, I just think that's really important that we put it in context.
We don't all deal with budgets like this. I never dealt with budgets like
this. I don't deal with budgets like this in my own personal finance.
But I think it's important that we understand it, and we need to get— we
need to get to a place where we can actually have a meaningful conversation and
quit harping on those things that are just myopic
and lost, in my opinion. They're just lost.
And I think it's because we haven't done a good job of giving context.
I think that's part of the problem, is we haven't done a good
job of giving context so that she— so that our citizens can understand what
we see and what we're dealing with on a daily, weekly basis.
And so that, that's where we need to do better. And I think it's probably
important to note too that with the council passage of
its code last week, it bound themselves by
ordinance to use those dollars
in— Orderly. For public safety, as they committed to verbally.
Now they're bound by ordinance to use those for public safety
purposes, and that $4.5 million is really only half of the
cost of the police department's contract. So money is still coming
from other places to pay for But all of the public's
property tax dollars, 100%, whether they come from residential or commercial or data
centers or wherever, all property taxes go to pay for nothing but
public safety because we all benefit from it together. All right, I'm going to
pull out my inner Marcus and say we're getting off track. Let's go.
And say we got to bring this back to the item at hand and ask
if there's any other questions. I think we've answered those questions and we're happy to
have conversations further. Even if we don't disagree, don't agree,
I still love the conversation. So no
other questions? Terrence, do you have anything to add?
If not, Brett, go to work. I'll make a motion. Mayor, I move
that the Eagle Mountain City Council approve Resolution 16A,
approving the first amendment to the fiscal year, the budget fiscal year 2026-2027.
2027 annual budget as presented by Terrence.
Second. Okay, and just to be clear, that was with the,
uh, with the— okay, although I think it was presented as he presented
it. Yep. Yes. Okay, uh, we have a motion by Councilmember Wright and a second
by Councilmember Clark, and we'll start the vote with Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Councilmember Clark.
Yes. Councilmember Wright. Yes. Okay, that motion passes.
All right.
Marcus, stay on topic.
We're going to have some training and learn
about the Open and Public Meetings Act.
And, and maybe as an opening to this too, uh, this is Open and Public
Meetings Act for the public's sake. Uh, once a year we're required to provide
that training to our elected leaders. And so, Mayor, I, I would highly encourage you
to ask our 2 council members who are not here to watch this portion of
the meeting because this is really beneficial. But not only them, but our planning commissioners
and any other boards that's really— actually, uh, so I delivered
this to planning commission last week, and I talked to the
board between the meetings and told them they should listen to this. So,
and I know Charlotte's still here, um, so we can pass this information
on. I believe Jesse might be online. So, um,
she is online. So I think I think, to your
point, I agree, and I think we need to make sure that gets out.
Steve is— maybe we lost Steve, but whoever sits on those boards,
make sure that we get that out. There he is. I just couldn't see
you. Okay, so this is a combination
Open Meetings Act training and Municipal Ethics Act training. So we're
gonna start with a little video just to highlight the Importance
of understanding the rules. Okay, please thumb—
oh, there you go. I tell you, I gotta plead ignorance on this thing because
if anyone had said anything to me at all when I first started here that
that sort of thing was frowned upon,
you know, because I've worked in a lot of offices and I tell
you, people do that all the time. So, uh,
It's important to understand the rules. Ignorance is not an excuse.
It's a well-known maxim in the law. As an attorney,
I always advise clients, you know, you need to inform yourself, because ultimately
you're responsible to abide by the Open Meetings Act in this case.
So the purpose of the Open Meetings Act is the intent of the legislature that
the state, its agencies, and its political subdivisions,
including cities, take their actions openly and conduct their deliberations openly.
So that's why we have open meetings. That's why we make
these decisions in meetings like this, is so that it can be done in
the face of the public. These laws are important so that
citizens can see how the process works. Okay. So just
as an opener, potential penalties for violations of the Open
Meetings Act are somebody could institute a suit to void a final
action on something that's done in violation of the Act, that there are criminal
punishments involved, and ultimately a violation by an
elected official could lead to expulsion from office.
Okay, so the default rule is
that a meeting is open to the public. Meetings can be closed only for very
specific reasons outlined in the statute. I think
you're very familiar with What the reasons we usually close
a meeting for are related to pending or reasonably imminent litigation,
land purchases or sales,
or discussing the competency of an individual.
So whether that's in relation to hiring or firing, or if it's in relation to
contracting, or whatever the case may be. So it requires
a 2/3 supermajority vote to close a meeting. So in this case,
it would typically require require 4 votes.
Okay. So the question then is, what is a meeting? It is actually
a term that is defined in the Open Meetings Act. It is the convening of
a public body with a quorum present. So the convening is done
by the person with authority to convene a meeting, which in
our case is either the mayor or 2 council members.
So with a quorum present, which is 3 individuals on
the council exclusive of the mayor,
including a workshop or an executive session, whether in person or by means
of electronic communications, for the purpose of discussing, receiving comments from
the public about, or acting upon a matter over which the public body has
jurisdiction or advisory power. So the simplified
version of this is a— you have a quorum, so 3 individuals, and you are
discussing public business. Yes, are you going to say something?
Craig? Oh, it looked like you were gonna say something, okay. So this, a meeting
can include phone calls, video conferencing, emails, text messages, et cetera.
It doesn't have to be a formal setting. So the
rule of thumb is if you are in a quorum, don't talk about
city business, which I know can be hard to do because what one thing do
you all have in common? So,
it's that you're all elected to represent the city. So as
I said, a quorum is 3 members of the city council exclusive of the mayor.
It's specific in the statute. The mayor does not count
in determining whether a quorum exists. Chances of social meetings
are not subject to the Open Public Meetings Act,
but they cannot be used to circumvent the requirements of the act. So if you
wanna go bowling together, that's fine. Just don't discuss city business.
It's not a meeting and therefore not subject to the act.
Again, typically we would only discuss items that are properly
noticed. There's, again, noticing requirements, there's emergency
noticing requirements, all sorts of things. But you can't take final
action on anything that isn't properly noticed. So if there's a discussion item and
you— there's something that comes up where it says City Manager items and we talk
about it, you couldn't take final action on that unless you specified what
item you were going to take final action and notice that that separately.
Okay. So this is an important one because this is,
I think, 2 years old now since the legislature added this. I think it's an
important rule, which is individuals constituting
a quorum of a public body such as the city council may not act
together outside a meeting in a concerted and deliberate way to predetermine an action to
be taken at the meeting on a relevant matter. And relevant matter is a defined
term. It's just anything within your jurisdiction. So, what that
means is that if one councilmember talks to a second councilmember
about a relevant matter, that's fine. They can
even predetermine their action if they want. I wouldn't advise it, but that is not
against the law. If they then talk to a third councilmember,
even if it's not all together at one time,
then that, and they predetermine the action, that would be considered a violation. And here's
a good example of it. I think most of you have seen this.
But I think it's hard to find Open and Public Meetings
Act videos, but this is a good one, and from a— you wouldn't expect
it from casino. Chairman, members of the commission,
Mr. Wollstein is pleased to be here today. And when the day finally came,
I was ready. I felt so confident that all I had to do was
present my case. And we have documents, one of which is
a report by retired FBI agents which completely absolves
Mr. Rothstein from any wrongdoing. I'd like this marked, Mr. Chairman. Pardon me, Counselor,
before you continue. No, I want to have this marked. This commission is prepared to
act on a motion denying the Rothstein application. Deny it! Do I hear a
motion seconded? Mr. Chairman. Mr. Chairman, I second the motion. Do I
have a vote on the motion? Mr. Chairman. Aye. Aye. Aye.
The ayes have it. This hearing is adjourned.
Okay, so I show that video because it I think
demonstrates the rationale behind the Open and Public Meetings Act. Here,
obviously, you see this really, you know, very full table
full of what appear to be case reporters. I'm not sure why they would need
half a dozen case reporters filled with mostly irrelevant cases,
but apparently they have that. They have a bunch of documents. They spent hours preparing
for this. And before they've had any discussion on the matter, they vote and decide
it. Obviously, this is not the purpose of the Open and Public Meetings Act.
What we want to do is have that deliberation, let them present their case,
deliberate about it openly, and then make a decision, not have it predetermined like it
was, as what happened in this case.
So now I'm going to go with some hypotheticals.
Hypothetical 1, and I've changed these from previous presentations.
So Councilmember A meets with Councilmember B
to discuss a preliminary plat application coming coming before the city council on the next
agenda. Councilmember A convinces Councilmember B that preliminary plat does
not meet the legal requirements. They decide to vote against it at the next meeting.
Is this a violation of the Open and Public Meetings Act?
It's okay to answer if you know the answer.
Not a violation. Why? It's just
2 of them. Does not constitute a quorum. But it still does create—
But what you don't want to do is predetermine an outcome. Yes.
That's the key. That's where you're trying to trick us. So I
would say that this is not a violation, but does somewhat go against the spirit.
But it kind of borders on one that is potential.
Well, this is not a violation because there's not a quorum. Now, I would not
recommend that you predetermine actions. It's fine to
form opinions, of Of course. You look at the preliminary plat, you think it doesn't
meet the legal requirements, it's natural to form that opinion based upon review.
I would expect you to form an opinion. Certainly, maybe not set in stone,
but certainly form an opinion prior to the meeting, because that means you studied the
issue. What, you know, even predetermining in this sense
is not actually a violation, but maybe against the spirit of what you're being asked
to do. Okay. Hypothetical number 2.
Councilmember A speaks to the mayor about a development agreement on the next On next
week's city council agenda, and they agree on several specific changes that need, sorry,
there's a typo, need to be made to the agreement. The mayor contacts Councilmember
B and discusses the matter. Councilmember B agrees that the changes are
important and indicates that he will support them. Is this a violation of the Open
and Public Meetings Act? Trick question.
It's not very tricky.
So it is not a violation. Again, because the
mayor does not count towards the quorum, that's the principle being illustrated. Again,
when you're going through agreements, if you think something needs to be changed,
obviously you're the policymakers, you make those decisions,
and it's okay to form an opinion on that.
Obviously you should be open to reconsideration or
amendment or modification of those, what changes you think need to be made, or be
willing to be convinced that they don't need to be made. and discuss that in
the meeting. But forming these opinions and even discussing it among 2 council
members and then the mayor is not a violation of the Act. So there
you go. Hypothetical 3. Council Member A speaks to Council Member B
about a rezone application in front of the City Council next week. He convinces
Council Member B to recommend approval. Council Member B speaks to Council Member C to
get her support. Council Member C dislikes the rezone application
and declines to give support. Is this a violation of the Open Public Meetings Act?
Yes, because they combined A, B,
and C and had a discussion by proxy.
That's correct. So the fact that Councilmember— Oh, sorry.
The fact that Councilmember C predetermined
something different than Councilmembers A and B does not matter. Okay.
So it's still a violation. Okay, hypothetical 4,
same facts except that the discussion occurs via text messaging.
Is this a violation?
Still yes. Still yes. Okay. Text messaging doesn't change the
legal landscape. It's still a violation. Okay, hypothetical 5,
during an open meeting, council votes to go into closed session. During the closed session,
the city council discusses potentially suing a contractor over a bridge contract issue.
Councilmember A asks how this will affect other agreements with the same contractor.
Is this a violation of the Open Public Meetings Act?
Got it. Well, they, they can go to a closed session because they're talking
about litigation, so that's acceptable. They can
discuss that, and I think they can discuss the ramifications of it, is my own
opinion of it, but I don't know on that second part of the question.
The problem comes for me when Member A asks how this will affect other agreements
with the same contractor, because those are not part of the closed session item.
So my favorite answer in the law is, of course, it depends,
right? So I think a narrow discussion of how potentially
suing a contractor, which again would fall within the reasonably imminent litigation, because you're
actively discussing, should we sue this person?
You know, whether, how that will affect the total landscape with that same person,
and the effects of actually instituting a lawsuit,
I think if you keep it in that narrow scope, you're fine. The issue
comes when you don't keep it in the narrow scope, and then you run into
problems. So, it's one where you have to be very vigilant in making
sure that your discussion is specific to the lawsuit,
and so your discussion of those other agreements is specific to the lawsuit's
impact on them. And that's why you sit in every closed session and keep us
on track if we start to wander slightly. I mean, Marcus has us
on a short leash. Anybody who sees me out here knows I like to enforce
rules, or at least I'm willing to.
Okay, hypothetical 6. Same facts as hypothetical 5.
Councilmember Beas About whether the city should terminate the contract,
and what contractor the city should procure as a replacement.
Is this a violation? Yes. Yes,
and again, this is what I talked about last one, right? We gotta keep ourselves
very narrowly tailored on that discussion of those other
contracts, and discussion of the lawsuit. And the second we start talking about,
well, who should we get to replace them, then you're all of a sudden,
you've crossed the line. So don't do that. Okay,
hypothetical 7. During closed session, the city council discusses the professional
competence of Company 1, whose services the city is considering using. Is this a violation
of the Open and Public Meetings Act?
Yes. Why? Because it's an individual, not a company.
That's correct. So the— you're allowed
to discuss the professional competence Competence of an individual. Individual is defined
as a human being in this context. Sometimes we use the word individual in the
law to not just mean human beings, but also legal entities.
But in the context of the Open and Public Meetings Act, it literally means a
human being. So talking about a company, unless you're talking about— unless
company 1 is like an individual, say like it's
a lobbyist, and they're the company, it's just one individual, then maybe you could
talk about that individual's competence. But as
far as, you know, you're talking about like Meta, obviously no.
You're not talking about anyone's, any specific
individual's confidence. You're talking about the company. So that would be a violation. Okay.
So thus concludes the Open Meetings Act portion
of the training. Are there any questions?
No, but it's always fun to have you try and trick us, Marcus. I do
what I can. Try to make it interesting,
so try to make you think so it's not just rote memorization but
actually critical thinking. So, alrighty, let's go to Municipal
Officers and Employees Ethics Act. All right,
from the beginning. Okay.
So the purpose of this, of the act,
is to establish standards for conduct for municipal officers and employees and to require these
persons disclose actual or potential conflicts of interest between
their public duties and their personal interests. Okay.
So here's the first thing. It's unlawful to disclose improperly used private,
controlled, or protected information acquired by reason of your official position
in the course of your duties in order to further substantially your
personal economic interests or to secure special privileges or exemption
for you or for others. Okay. So this
is pretty straightforward. In the event that you come into contact,
and I don't think most of you would on any sort of regular basis,
but in the event you come into contact with private control or protected records
or other information that would fall under that, you can't use that for your own
gain. I think this falls in the common sense category.
Whenever you obtain something via your public
service and you try using it for personal gain. I think common sense tells you
that might be wrong. Okay.
It is unlawful to— and so anytime— so I just want to clarify
something. Anytime in the law we say unlawful, it means it's a crime. So sometimes
you say, you know, you can violate the law and it's just there's implications
where you could be liable in a civil suit. But anytime you use the word
in a statute or in an ordinance that says it's unlawful, it means you're committing
a crime and could be prosecuted. Okay, it is
unlawful to knowingly receive, accept, take, seek, or solicit directly or indirectly
for the officer or employer or for another a gift of
substantial value or a substantial economic benefit tantamount to a gift that would
tender improperly influence a reasonable person in your position to depart from
faithful and impartial discharge of your duties, that you know or should
know that under the circumstances is primarily for the purposes
of rewarding you for official action taken.
So either of those things. However, there is a safe harbor provision
that says an occasional gift valued at under $50 is okay.
So if you're at a conference and you receive
a free meal from a sponsor and it's less than $50,
that's presumptively okay. Again,
these are— That's the safe harbor provision.
So that's a presumption. It doesn't mean that
because something's $51, it's necessarily a violation. That's always a case-by-case
basis. The $50 is simply a safe harbor provision.
So when I was younger, not so much anymore, I used to like Law and
Order. When I became a lawyer, I started to dislike it, because I see all
the things that are wrong with it. But when I was younger, I liked
it. And there's one episode where one
individual murders his brother, and his mother, who is a rather
wealthy individual, a wealthy businesswoman,
then essentially bribes a judge to
let the surviving son, make a ruling in favor of
the surviving son to get compelling evidence of
his guilt suppressed, and thus the case dismissed.
And so the way that she undertakes to
provide this bribe is to arrange with the bank that
her business banks with to provide a substantially below market rate loan for
the mortgage for the judge. So she's not actually providing anything, and that
is basically, if you look at the definition of substantial
economic benefit tantamount to a gift, that is basically what is described,
is what occurred in that. Episode. So anything
where you would receive something of value,
whether it's, you know, somebody is going to sell you something at below market rate
because you are on the city council or an elected official, that would
be problematic. You know,
again, the language here is it
has to be something that would tend to improperly influence you.
Or that would tend to be a reward.
So, you know, you get invited by a developer to some
sort of event that they're hosting, not just for the city, but for many,
including employees and elected officials of the city, and they're
offering you benefits at that thing, then it's just a question of, is this less
than $50? If it is, I'm probably under safe harbor.
If it's more than that, then it's probably a bad idea to accept,
because it could be construed as a reward
for official action taken. Okay, so let's
go to another video. Hey, Tom, check it out.
Norton Construction just sent this over. Whoa, mama.
I love Great Lakes wine. No, no, no, no, no.
You know as well as I do that we are not allowed to accept gifts
over $25 for corruption reasons. We live in a fishbowl,
and the public is always watching. But you cannot enjoy this basket.
I'm so sorry. And so to avoid temptation, I'm going to lock it up.
Okay. So apparently the rule in Pawnee is $25,
not $50, as a safe harbor provision.
But so again, that's kind of illustrative of the,
you know, if it's something You know, when in doubt, you know, just don't accept
the gift. I mean, maybe this is a bit overkill here, but there was booze
in that if you watched the episode. So probably not a good idea to accept.
Ooh, hey. Okay. So, all right. It's unlawful
to use or attempt to use the officer's or employee's official position to further your
personal economic interests or secure special privileges for you or others.
Again, this kind of goes in the common sense territory.
Don't use your office to make money for you or your family
or your friends. So, cut.
There's a million ways to exploit your power, but have I ever given in to
that temptation? No, never. I'm not that kind of politician. Official Parks
and Rec business. Just need to grab a quick hot dog. Sorry about that,
little girl, you can have the next one. I have a moral code and I
never violate it. People look at me and they say, wow, Tom, You are so
pure. You're like a brown Superman with a beard that just stands for justice
and truth and the American way. Yeah, don't do
that. So obviously this is, you know, a humorous representation
of kind of what not to do, and it's obviously on a very small scale.
But yes, we don't use our office, our position
for personal gain. They call it public service
for a reason, so. Okay, so these violations can be prosecuted
criminally, and depending on the value of any benefit received, it could be up to
a second-degree felony. Anywhere from a Class B misdemeanor to a second-degree felony depending
on the value of the gift or other benefit received.
So just don't do it. When in doubt,
you have my number, so just call, we'll discuss.
And yes. Okay, so part of the Ethics Act,
In fact, I would say the majority of it is dedicated to disclosure requirements.
So it is an offense, which is another term that
means it's unlawful, for a city council member to receive or agree
to receive compensation for assisting any person or business entity in any transaction
involving the city, unless you
file a sworn statement with the mayor.
And follow the requirements. You give a description of what's going
on, and you disclose it in an open City Council meeting.
So those are the required disclosures.
Under state law, that's all you're required to do. As we'll discuss later, under city
law, you would also be required to recuse yourself from any action related
to that. So,
okay, more disclosures. A City Council member who is an officer, director,
agent, or employee, or the owner of substantial interest in any business
entity which is subject to the regulation of
the city shall disclose the position held and the nature and
value of the interest upon first becoming appointed or elected to
the city council, typically elected,
and anytime thereafter if any of the information
changes. So disclosure is in the
form of a sworn statement to the mayor and the city recorder. And the mayor
provides a copy or outlines the substance of the disclosure to the remainder of the
city council. Okay, an interest of $5,000 or less need not be disclosed,
and that's out of the statute. A city
council member who is an officer, director, agent, employee, or owner of substantial interest in
a business entity which does or anticipates doing business with the city shall publicly
disclose to the members of the city council immediately prior to any discussion of any—
by such body concerning matters related to that entity. And the nature
of the interest. So again, so there's the disclosure you give to the mayor in
writing, and then hey, now it's got business in city
council on the agenda. You have to disclose it immediately before the item is called
on the agenda. And you know, again, under city code, you would also recuse yourself.
So violation of the disclosure requirements could lead to expulsion
under the statute if they were proven would lead to expulsion. And it
also makes any action in violation of the disclosure requirements voidable,
which is important distinction under the law. Void and voidable mean
2 different things. Void means it never took effect.
Voidable means if you do certain things after the fact, you can
void the action. So you can void it. It's not necessarily
per se voided.
Okay. All right.
City code. Each public official who is a member of the city council shall
disclose disclose every conflict prior to consideration of any
action.
And again, also for purposes of
this chapter, the official has a conflict of interest if they know or have reason
to know that a parent, spouse, sibling, or member
of the same household, agent, principal, client, employer, or employee also would
violate any of these things or would meet any of these requirements. So if you're
required to disclose, Under the state act,
you have to both disclose and then recuse. If you have an ownership interest
in a business having matters under proper consideration for the city council, same.
All these things would involve disclosure and then for an agenda item
recusal. Have an ownership interest in property within
Eagle Mountain City for which zoning, conditional use, or development
approvals are under consideration. This would not
apply to a principal residence. So if you own
a house, you live in it, that would not apply. But otherwise,
yes. Represents as an agent,
professional services contractor, or other advisor individual with matters under consideration
before the City Council. Again, if in your day job you're doing something to that
effect, for example, say you worked for LRB,
there are municipal financial advisors.
When we're doing municipal financial stuff, then you would have to recuse from that.
Okay, so has an ownership interest in business or property
that has been issued a business license by Eagle Mountain,
uses or develops property located within the city limits
other than your personal residence, And which offers
the same goods, products, or services, or would use or develop property in a similar
way as a business or property which has matter. So again, this is related to,
you have, you know, you own property and you're a competitor to
the person that's being, that's getting
rezoned. So you would have a conflict there because they're
asking for a rezone and you're their competitor.
Again, this relates to zoning, conditional use, or development approvals.
If you own property that's gonna be affected indirectly or directly,
other than, again, other than a primary residence, then you would have to disclose and
recuse. If you have agreement with party seeking approval
that would finally financially benefit you,
then same thing. So hypothetical 1. Okay, City Councilmember
A attends a conference to receive training on his duties. Company 1 invites
City Councilmember A to dinner and pays. Company 1 has business before the City Council.
The cost of the dinner is $40. Is this a violation of
the Ethics Act?
No, because it's under $50. That's correct.
Safe harbor provision, you know,
again, the standard is if it would you know,
reasonable person would, you know,
would be, I guess, influenced to
not impartially discharge their duties. However, if it's under $50, there's the
presumption that it's fine. Okay.
Dinner costs $75. Otherwise, it's the same hypothetical.
Is this a violation? I would say probably not.
It's outside the safe harbor provision. Would a $75 meal cause
you to change your vote? So I would assume not. But again,
at $51, is that a per se violation? No,
it's probably not a violation. At a $10,000
meal, they take you to some White House fundraiser dinner, it's probably
a violation. Where you draw the line in between those 2 numbers is unclear.
So my advice is always just keep it under $50. You don't have a problem.
At $75, is it not a per se violation? But it could be.
So that's why I say it's probably not. You know, in some contexts
maybe. But again, my advice would be don't
do it. So, okay.
Hypothetical 3, city council member has a 25% ownership interest in Company 2.
Company 2 does business before the city council. Does City Council Member B have any
obligations under state or city ethics laws? If so, what are those obligations?
Yes, you have to disclose your ownership interest, right? And,
uh, let's see, and then if that business
comes before the council, then you need to recuse yourself and walk
away and allow the council to deal with that outside
of your presence. Yes, so you would have the written disclosure obligation to
send something to the mayor,
also would have a disclosure obligation in the meeting to disclose it immediately
before consideration and recuse yourself. Okay.
All right. So last part is standards for civil discourse.
So this is in the city code. I think it relates to
ethics in that obviously the way that we relate
and talk to each other and the people who come and do business before the
council, I think, has an ethical implication. And so we do have these standards for
civil discourse. And state
code basically says you should adopt them, and that's what that
reference to state code is in here. But the
purpose is, again, to meet our obligations to each other and to the public
by following these. So let's talk about the standards.
Conduct or language that is condescending, uncivil, abrasive, abusive, hostile,
or obstructive impedes the fundamental goal of participating in civil discourse
and public processes, and the rational, peaceful, and efficient resolution of
decisions, and is a violation of this standard. Such conduct
tends to delay and often to deny resolution of issues in the public interest.
So that's something to keep in mind, is that when we are
speaking to one another, sometimes discussions can get heated, or when an
applicant comes and they have a proposal that
sometimes discussions can get heated. It's always
good to keep in mind to keep our conduct
and our language within these bounds. So, you know,
they may say something that you think is stupid or that doesn't make any
sense. We still treat them with respect and
we explain why we hold that position, not just say,
hey, that's stupid. So. Elected and
appointed officials and city employees should exhibit courtesy, candor, and cooperation in dealing with each
other and the public and in the administration of the city. Elected officials,
members of city boards and commissions, and employees shall not, without an adequate factual
basis, attribute to other persons improper motives, purpose, or conduct.
Each person affiliated with the city should avoid hostile, demeaning, or humiliating conduct and
words in written and oral communications. Neither written submissions nor oral statements or
conduct should disparage the integrity, intelligence, morals, ethics, or personal behavior of others. So,
uh, pretty, uh, self-explanatory. And that
is the end of the presentation. Are there any questions?
Very thorough. Thank you for the reminder, Marcus.
Perfect. Thank you. I was thinking to myself as you go through
that, some of the other things that I just highlight as a reminder Of course,
that was ethics and somewhat code of conduct, but in our own code,
you know, Section 2, just a reminder to read that,
and maybe the way we treat each other and talk to each other, a reminder
to do it civilly and treat
people with respect. So I sure appreciate that.
Is John still with us? There he is. You move
to a new seat every day, I swear. It's not your fault.
Good evening, Mayor, Council. Um, so I
finally got the quotes back for the reinforced— or the precast
fences. Um, to have a custom panel will range
between $20,000 to $30,000 to have it designed,
and then it would be no more than any regular panel
after that. So if they wanted to— if we want to come with a design
standard, we can create panels, a couple panels,
and then we can have whatever they have as fencing material
to come back to make it look blended all together.
Do you think that the arts facility fund, a quarter
of a percent could be used for that if it was designed in such a
way? Because I'm all about finding
alternate funding sources for it. I know that we had discussed
something like that. I think certainly,
um, streets, you know, a streets project,
a percentage needs to go towards arts, and you're beautifying the
street while also Providing the safety enhancements, and that's really what it all comes down
to. You want to have a safety enhancement, but the beautification aspects of it,
if the cost is the same and yet this element adds the
beauty to our community and continuity, sure, absolutely.
It kind of reminds me of the bridges on I-15 that either
have like a wildlife something or the Olympic
something that's on them, and they're restricted funds that
can only be used for that. So it's like Can we kill 2 birds with
one stone? Not literally birds.
I think one of the goals— this is something I think Rich and I was
kind of talking about a long time ago— and could we, you know, have our
emblem on, on these walls and different things? Uh,
but really the goal was to save money for
the contractors to be able to have our own Forms, and all we'd be buying
is concrete at that point. So I think I heard you say, uh, same money
as far as the pour. Yeah, after they
design it, it would be just as expensive to buy that panel versus one off
the stock panel they already have. If you're gonna buy it. Yeah,
if you're gonna have somebody custom pour it. But if we found
a way to get a concrete company to store
those panels, I mean, They're obviously making a profit
margin by building those panels, so I would hope that it's not— that
if we had our own forms, that there's a cost savings. What's the
longevity of those forms? What's the lifespan of them? Do you have any idea,
John? Anywhere from 800 to 1,000
pours. So you would only have a few of those custom panels mixed in
with a standard panel. Yeah, I mean,
that makes sense to me. I just wanted to know how often are we gonna
be looking at a mold charge? Right. In one of my previous
cities, there was an HOA,
a larger— yes, okay, it was Santa Clarita. In Santa Clarita, there was
a large HOA and large subdivision,
Summit Ridge community, where the HOA
went and the city The master builder actually went out, got the
forms, pre-built all of the
panels, and those were available as different builders
were building different areas so that they had continuity. And it just made
it one source and easier, and they were able to buy it wholesale. So it's
just an option, but— So,
So anything else on that? You said $30,000 and then— $20,000 to
$30,000, depending— it depends on how intricate the design gets.
The harder it gets, the more expensive it gets for the
poor. So an E might be a little cheaper than the full logo.
Right. Or just— or the eagle. The other thing is,
some of these places, some of the 3 different manufacturers I was able to get
a hold of, 2 of them— Pretty much do
the installs themselves. They do sell some to third-party fence
installers, but most of this they do the install themselves too. So we
could be in a position where we'd be locked into one installer.
Yeah, I mean, if, if we own the forms, we own the forms.
We can move and we could pour here if we wanted. But if we're asking
somebody to store stuff, we'd be— probably
have some kind of arrangement. But I So I don't know how to really
handle this report. It's something that I think we need to talk about. So I
don't want you to check it off as done. I think we need to maybe
bring it with Evan or something to a discussion because now it's—
now we have the info. What do we wanna do with it? We could put
it on a work meeting and let you guys have an open public meeting about
it. So then in that case, you wanna assign that out to,
as far as who's gonna get some info and bring us, you know,
I mean, we got the costs, just now what do we wanna
do with it? Whether it's design, do we do a couple logos, whatever.
And I could see what other cities are doing as well. Just do a simple
blast to the City Managers Association, that type of thing. I know Herriman has some
custom ones. So next time we have a light agenda,
Lacey, we'll add this on. So plan on like 2028.
I wanna make it clear that I don't wanna spend extra money on it,
but if there's restricted funds that can only be used for something
like the art piece or whatever, we talked about this
when the art quarter of a percentage was created, and I remember Mayor,
when he was on council, talked about manhole covers. Like,
we have to buy manhole covers anyway for a project.
We could put a design into them to— Do whatever, and that's
just part of it. So like, I don't want us to
try to find money from someplace else, but if we have it in an art
fund, to me that seems like a good use for it.
I'm fine with whatever direction you guys say on that, even though I might
slightly disagree because of this. The goal is to help
improve some of the developers that haven't, you know, that don't
find that cost-effective. This is a way for us to get an elevated fence and
keep it cost-effective. So I think there's some value in that.
Although I do wanna use restricted funds, I don't know that that's a limiting
factor is all I'm saying. So yeah, let's bring that back with
those type of discussion points that we can hash out.
Next? At the next meeting, you're gonna discuss
The traffic calming, traffic study stuff. So that is coming back.
And that is all I have for you for all the updates on my side.
The only thing is, is there anything you guys want to add? I think just
for Councilmember Weitig's sake, I'm going to throw this out there. As that comes,
tonight it was brought up, the funding source. I know we set aside $250,000.
$200,000? It was $250,000. Anyway, I think we need to
know if there's, you know, 5 suggestions You
know, each one of those allocate a dollar amount so that we know kind of
what we're dealing with when we—I mean, we just—we're kind of throwing darts to try
to get this project moving, and we need to know what it's going to cost.
Yep. So we're meeting with them next week, and we'll make sure that we have
some estimates in there for all the recommended traffic calming solutions for each location.
I'm pretty sure you've been in the same meetings as me, so you've heard kind
of the higher priorities. Maybe start with those, and you know that we kind of
bring. So it will come with a. prioritization. That's what I'm hoping.
Our goal is to present like a matrix, so we have like all the locations,
what they recommended for the solution, and then also we thought
for some locations, you know, why the speed tables may or may not work for
that location and kind of talk through options so you guys can see it and
make those decisions.
So one thing we talked briefly about, ladder signs and
adding more ladder signs to the part of the city because we've had growth there.
Where, where are we at with that discussion?
We were waiting to hear back from that. Mayor, do I need to get up
and leave? Huh?
Okay, we won't have a quorum, but I— we're just
So, and let me reach back around. The chamber was supposed to be, uh,
giving us information on that. I haven't heard back from them, so let me reach
out to them. Sounds good. Okay,
was there anything else on that? Unless you have something else.
We can wait for a minute. We can do some liaison
reports. It's not a voting issue, so.
She's back. Okay, no sweat.
Anything to report? Laison? I'm meeting with the library board for
a quarterly meeting next week.
Chamber of Commerce is rocking and rolling. Met with them last month
and they're just, we're very blessed to have a very active,
robust chamber and they're doing a great job.
And I visited Shop Fest, it's epic.
We're very blessed to have it.
And the— and we had a meeting with the Eagle Mountain, the Youth Council,
and there's tons of energy with the Youth Council right now. We have tons of
people coming to our meetings, and it's just awesome
to see that. And the youth are providing lots of ideas. This last meeting was
amazing. The youth are leading it, they're driving it, they're providing a lot of input
as to what's going on, and it's, it's just, it's an awesome organization
to be a part of right now. Yeah, there's been some youth that have reached
out to me that want to join. But they wouldn't be voting members at this
point because of the new— Correct. They would not be voting members, but they
can definitely come to the meetings and give their input for sure and participate.
Yeah, and I wonder if they could be voted into the quorum
if that became, you know, I mean— We could.
We just wanted to cut it off at some point, but I mean, could we?
We could for sure do something like that. I mean, it's— Do—
does that discourage people to join it late? You know, I mean— Yeah,
I mean, we ran a few weeks before we cut it off, but— Let's just
see what it does. But I know there's a couple, and I think maybe you've
been made aware of some of them. I'm aware of one person that
reached out, and yeah, but I said come to the meeting
and participate. I mean, at this point, there's so many people
that are voting that one additional vote— I'm not that it's gonna persuade things one
way or the other, 'cause most everything they talk about seems unanimous anyway, or very
close to it. But what's powerful about people coming is they're giving
great ideas, and then there's just more bodies
to enact those ideas as well. I should have said this earlier, but I'm even
wearing my— I went to the suicide walk and
the youth council was there, and I've got my— I went and walked, and that
was cool. Some of the events I've been involved in the last couple weeks have
been pretty fun, and I, for some reason, I just believe in this stuff,
so I still wear the wristband I got. So that
was cool. And the Youth Council did— I see them everywhere. It's just fun.
Anything else?
Yeah, just quickly, Mayor. I mean,
LPC, I volunteered to be part of their water
committee. I'm not surprised. So just so that you're aware of that,
and Justin Lee confirmed that they're going to allow me to
help with that. And we do have LPC next Monday, just a reminder
for you and for Ben. Seniors— Wasn't Zach on there as
a voting member? Zach as well. Yeah, I'll reach out to Zach and remind him.
And then the seniors have got, you know, our chili cook-off coming up in
October, as I remember, and they're starting to work towards
the donations for the Thanksgiving basket. So if you
want to help with that, reach out to the seniors. They'll have a list of
Items that you can contribute. I, I see 5 o'clock, 5 PM senior
games on September 28th. That's on my calendar. But that
one got, that one got moved? Yeah, it got shifted around. That's the chili cook-off?
Yeah, they, they moved it to the end of October. I need to verify the
date. Okay, I see October— sorry, October 26th is what I see on that.
The September 28th I can remove off my calendar? Yep, take it off.
They changed it. Okay, they switched it on us. Got it.
And then just DRC. I hope each of you get
a chance to sit on the DRC for a year. It will really increase
your appreciation for what our staff does preliminarily before we
ever see anything. Mayor kind of
gave me an assignment since I'm an evangelist
for UTA to meet with
Chandler, who's their government and community outreach person.
One of the issues that we found with UTA, the new on-demand system,
is that the system won't take
you more than 6 miles unless you're going to a transit station. Well,
for anybody who lives in City Center and needs to get
to a job at Ridley's or Walmart, you can't get there.
And that's a problem for a city that spans from Cedar
Hills to Provo. Thank you. So we are
working with them to create some special
points that could get them up to
Walmart, and maybe Walmart's one of them, City Hall.
That is something that we're working on. I had the opportunity to go to the
kind of grand opening of On Demand, and that was really good because
I made sure everyone who had anything to do with planning at UTA
heard about the 6-mile limitation,
and it was good. I got to be there to represent our city while mayor
was in New York. I think it was when you
were busy with that. No, I think you were gone because I
remember telling the other mayors. Yeah, that one, that one I met with Chandler
and he— and by the way, he gave me like 4 on-demand passes that I
would offer to anybody that would try and use it or any of the council.
One of the— so 9 miles to Saratoga, we've talked about, to the kind of
employment center where Costco is. And I was asking that we bump
that up to get a little further distance. And as long as they're not busy,
they've kind of been pretty lenient on that 6 miles, but that's the rule.
So we've gone to Skyler Beltran and asked him to expand that. And that's
where I passed the baton. I didn't have the bandwidth for that one. Well,
I also think that Part of the issue is that they have a limited number
of vehicles that are in the system, and we are out here on the
outskirts of it. If we can—
16 vehicles, and I think they had 1,000 rides the first day.
1,000 rides the first 9 days, but that's still a lot. Okay,
yeah, they gave me some stats. I was like, yeah, it was good. 'Cause at
the grand opening, they announced that it was 1,003 rides.
I think one thing that we as a city may need to consider is
finding funding or getting support from some
of the corporate partners within our boundaries to help fund additional
vehicles that are— will help staff
up more of the Eagle Mountain side of things
so that they can't say we don't have enough vehicles to
do that. This. So we'll go through the hoops of trying to get them to
add miles for us and add additional locations that
we can go to. But if that fails, which I'm
not completely convinced that it will
pass, like UTA has kind of let us down in the past,
if that's the case, then I think we as a council and a city need
to look at whether or not we seek funds from someone
or some entity to help pay for that because it's a huge benefit
to our residents. Council Member Wright just talked about our seniors,
Council Member Whiting talked about our youth. Everyone is
using this on demand and it's had a huge turnout. So I think it's something
for us just to think about. They said a lot of the kids, like kids
getting off of football practice because the buses have already left, have been using it.
So one of the other things that I think we could advocate, and we could
use the public to help us with this, is it's kind of meant
for those first and last miles to get you home from a bus stop or
something. But what would help is they will only do 6
miles in those cases, like, you know, to your home. But if
we identify Costco and Walmart and the high school,
they'll do 10 miles if it's one of, you know, a specific location.
Right. So we're trying to identify and employment areas. Exactly. I think
the inherent problem with their 6-mile limitation, Mayor, is that the
whole thing— the reason why they justified doing on-demand instead of
the bus route that they came and announced to us and said that they were
bringing and then pulled back— is that they want to find ridership
numbers. Well, if there's a third of our population is
outside of that 6-mile limit to get to Walmart or any other employment employment
centers, that means 1/3 automatically isn't going
to be factored into ridership numbers because it's not useful to them. And I think
that we have to be a squeaky wheel with this. And you
picked the right person to send. I was just going
to note that I got a call from Bob Allen with MAG letting
me know that Saratoga Springs and UTA are applying
for UDOT innovation grant money in order to expand and extend that
6-mile limit, and, and they wanted to know if Eagle Mountain
wanted to join in on that same application. I thought so. I know
that I sent something in to Mayor and Ben, and I think
that you guys had talked about Kimberly was going to have our grant writer
start looking at that. That deadline's coming up, and I don't want us to miss
out on it. When they had told me about it, there was only one other
city that had even submitted anything, and I know that Saratoga is doing it
too. We have a stronger case if we do something with them, I think.
Um, I, I had a meeting with Mark Christensen as well, and, um,
he, he encouraged us to put in an application. He thought that it
would be more beneficial. You can go up to $3 million per application,
and if we join in, then of course we're limited,
but there's an opportunity for both cities to put put in and potentially get $6
million for our region. So he encouraged us actually to do it
separately and try to meet that timeline. I think we could have a whole other
fleet with that amount of money. Does it say— is it $6
million in a year or $3 million in a year? I don't know
the specifics. Those are just numbers he provided. The grant's a 3-year funding,
so that number is probably a 3-year number total. But then,
then we would have to decide at that point whether we want— whether we have
some other funding Or we ask a corporation
to do a match. Or we petition
UTA to bring our own tax dollars back because we are already paying for those
dollars. That too. Of course,
you know, you've heard a lot of my reports with UFA and at the Capitol,
just different things I've got going. So unless you have specific questions,
I won't bore you with my 40 hours by Monday.
Mayor, can you, and maybe you talked about it and I just missed it,
did you talk at all about where we're at with UTA and the process
that we're trying to get figured out with UTA, not UTA,
UFA and UFSA and where we're
at with that? I met with them this morning and that we're
90% on the contract. She said she'll have it this week.
Yeah, that's what she indicated to me was that she's 90% finished with the draft
for me to review. Yep, that's what she said. And then we're working through
the tax code to try to figure out how to make sure that
we don't overtax in the transition or
undertax in the transition. And I think we got it figured out today, some solutions,
but it's more about also working with the state on
how to pull those funds in and to do it properly.
We've seen where mistakes have been made in other counties. So that's
really what the holdup. But right now, the answer to your question is December 31st,
2027. Right.
And we're also working with the league. We met with the league this week as
well to— because while it would
be an increase to our taxes, it would be a decrease to UFA
taxes. And the net effect is zero to our residents. And so Ultimately, it should
not trigger truth in taxation. It should be a net zero
to the residents. And is there a possibility for
legislative changes that would allow for that? Logan ran into a very similar
issue this year between the county that was providing a service and a city,
and they ran into that issue and it became— it got onto
the state's radar. We believe that that
would be very important for ARC. Thank you. because truth in taxation
should just be that, truth. And the truth is your
taxes wouldn't go up, it would just be transferring from one to another.
And the interesting thing is that the House rep, the rep that runs
a lot of the tax bills is in Logan. So it's
hopefully that it's on his radar. Well, I think it's
just like with the school districts. We have Alpine School District,
as a taxing entity right now. The Lake Mountain School District doesn't have
to do a truth in taxation to switch and bring that over. So I think
I'm glad you guys are pursuing that. That's what we're working
on. So yeah, lots of meetings. We've met with the league,
we've met with the state, we met with all those people this week. It's been
busy. It's Tuesday. Yes.
Anything else?
Yep. Go ahead. Mayor, I move that,
uh, we adjourn to a closed session for the purpose of discussing,
uh, discussion of pending or reasonable imminent litigation, the character,
professional competence, or physical or mental health of an individual,
the purchase, lease, sell, or exchange of real property, a proposed
development agreement, project proposal, or financing proposal related
to the development of land owned by the estate or political subdivision
and/or the deployment of security personnel, devices, or systems pursuant
to Section 52-4-205,
Subsat 1 of the Utah Code Annotated. Second.
All right, we do have a motion by Councilmember Wright and a second by Councilmember
Whiting, and we will return to this meeting afterwards to adjourn, just so you're
aware. We'll start the vote with Councilmember Clark. Yes.
Councilmember Wright. Yes. Councilmember Whiting? Yes.
Okay, at 9:17 we'll go to closed session. Sometimes I think
it's good to read those so that the public understands the things that we can
address. It's what we just learned.
You recording? All right, it is Maybe
my thing doesn't work. 10:21.
10:21, 10:22, and we're back in our regular
session, and I will entertain a motion. Motion to adjourn.
Second. Okay, I got Council Member Wright with the motion and Council
Member Clark with the second. All in favor? Aye.
Nobody opposed? That passed unanimous, and we are adjourned at 10:22.
I almost called you Council Member Wood, by the way.